Hello Freak pitches.
We're making podcasts magic again.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by ting ting
is a long time sponsor of the podcast and one that we have got universally
positive feedback from everybody that I know that I've turned onto.
It has saved money using Tang.
Tang is a cell phone service,
mobile phone service that uses the sprint backbone.
They have their own company though,
so they have their own rules like no contracts,
um,
no ETFs or early termination fees.
They have a new thing they would call the ETF relief program.
If you're paying an ETF,
come to ting and they will give you credit for 25% of your ETF up to $75 per
device.
Simply purchased your device through Ting port,
your number,
then submit your final bill with the ETF.
Detailed from your previous care carrier is ETF.
Like when you have a contract,
early termination fees.
Um,
they,
uh,
it's a,
it's a sweet cell phone company.
The way they have it set up.
I really enjoy a lot of the aspects of it.
One of the things that I really enjoy is there's no overage coverages or
penalties.
So like a lot of times it's like if you have one service and you'd go higher,
use more minutes,
you get hit with a penalty.
They don't do that.
They just charge you what you would have used or pay for you,
what what you have used and if you use too much or if you'd rather use too
little.
If you like,
if say had one contract and it was set up for,
you know,
x amount of minutes and you use something lower than that,
they'll knock you down to a lower rate and,
and credit you on your next pill.
It's beautiful.
Cancel anytime you want.
Brian has the new Samsung Galaxy s three there's a naked girl on your co.
Your phone,
dude.
Wow.
Wonder woman is hot as fuck to bed.
Wonder when we can't be just a big fucking angry fat,
broad cost small.
This one is Paris.
Why can't wonder woman would be like a really fit crossfit woman?
Why does she have to be this sex pot?
You know,
it's rude.
If I was willing,
I'd be pissed,
but I'm not.
Yeah,
the a iPhone looks very dainty
compared to that galaxy.
It kind of ruins it.
Like it kind of like after you go back to your iPhone,
it really feels like a little kids like phone now.
I didn't think that was going to happen quite honestly.
I thought I fucked up when I brought that thing.
I got it the first weekend I got it.
I went to England and it worked flawlessly over there and it's like,
wow.
You know,
maybe I get back home,
it's too big.
Maybe I'll just get the s four but then as time went on,
it became normal and as long as it fits in my pocket,
I have zero regrets.
I can have that phone.
I can officially say apple fucked up.
They fucked up.
Yup.
The Ain't better.
Hurry the fuck up with this new big phone supposedly making,
well the online experience is just a way better.
Way Better.
I mean,
I was watching Hulu plus on my phone last night in bed and it was fine.
It was this screens perfect for bed.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
I'm,
I'm a huge fan.
I'm a huge fan of a all of the galaxy devices,
but just android phones in general.
I have the HTC one as well.
I loved that phone to Alva.
Apple's made mistakes.
Um,
the beautiful thing about tank as well as you don't have to,
uh,
you don't have to compromise on devices.
They do have all the latest and greatest android phones,
including the galaxy s three or the galaxy s four.
They have that to the galaxy s three of the galaxy s four and the note three,
which is the one I have,
they have the HTC one.
They have all the,
the niftiest swiftest,
new beautiful galaxy phones and all the kids are using,
uh,
and um,
ting.
If you use the,
the,
if you go to rogan.ting.com,
uh,
you can save $25 on your first ting device when you sign up.
So visit rogan.ting.com couldn't recommend enough them enough.
Very cool company.
And all our friends that have used him of all reported that they've saved a ton
of money on their bill and it's just a more ethical,
it's more reasonably set up service.
I like what they're doing.
They're making plenty of money.
They don't have to rob.
You don't have to make you feel like you're getting fucked
like a sexy.
This one is,
if you go back to this,
if you want to go to the s four jet,
if you ever end up thinking that screens too big purple as for emptying.
Yeah,
as far as pretty God damn big,
it's still five inches.
You know,
it's just,
you get so greedy because the,
the note three,
it's just like a little laptop.
It's amazing for like,
I like I draw my notes on it,
I write them and it comes out just like you're writing on a piece of paper and
it's pressure sensitive or it's a pressure sensitive phone because I was using
it to draw.
It's like if you lightly draw,
it's just a little light,
you know,
like a little couple real pencil and then if you push harder it gets darker.
Just,
it's,
it's an amazing note.
Yeah.
These,
I was very impressed with the stylist.
I hadn't used a stylus on the,
anything in a long time since I had a palm pilot and there was a hunk of shit.
Remember that thing?
I still have mine and my trios,
remember that trios PalmPilots like the size of a thermos,
big fat,
stupid thing.
Remember when we used to try weird things like Dell cell phones and like that's
creepy.
Like smart phones,
you know what I mean?
Did that,
yeah,
there was a lot of different goofy cell phone ideas that didn't quite make it.
There was a bunch of Sony ones that use some,
whoa,
we got some weird crackling.
There was a bunch of Sony ones that use some really weird operating system
that's not around anymore.
You remember that operating system?
Yeah.
What was that?
Uh,
there was like a business operating system,
God dammit blackberry.
But it was,
no,
it was something totally different.
You know,
there was,
there was like,
there was one type of operating system that was getting used by like Nokia's and
a lot of weird,
uh,
cell phone companies.
And they had their own like little apps.
They all got smushed under the hurricane.
That was the iPhone.
Once the iPhone launched,
everybody was like,
fuck you.
Get out of the way.
It was so much better than everything else.
Like we both had android phones before we had the android too.
It was a Haka is shit.
Yeah.
The first one,
what was it?
The first droid,
they'll go horizon droid or awful.
There was so terrible.
You'd pick them up and you go back to the iPhone.
The iPhone was like your friend immediately.
Oh my sweetie,
I got your back.
It's not like that anymore.
Now it's actually swung the other way.
I this this a galaxy note three and it's huge screens if I'm sold.
Did you know you could also,
when you're on,
they have this thing called scrapbook.
Have you seen this?
When you're on a website you're like,
I got to remember this website.
So you take out the Stylus,
you circle whatever you want the picture to be and then it saves the whole
website and links the original website and just makes it a little thumbnail for
it.
So you could just go back and have like your own little scrapbook of websites.
Exactly.
That's,
and that's what it's called.
It's called scrapbook.
It's amazing.
It's so cool.
There's so many more options too.
When you start fucking around with all the different things you can do.
Apple fucked up and the watch,
I almost bought the watch but I didn't want
big and I'm like creepy.
You have a camera on it.
Like what am I supposed to be?
This is like 40 yeah.
It only lasts a day to write.
You have to charge it every day and that's has to be cancer of your wrist and
you don't want to fuck with your best lady.
Yeah.
You don't want to fuck with your wrist where in your left hand?
Don't you wear it on your laptop?
It makes it totally feel you don't want risk cancer,
Zombie masturbating,
all bad.
If you found out that cave,
you risk cancer.
I mean,
well if he gives you a brain cancer,
if you put it up to your head all day,
why wouldn't they give you a risk?
Cancer.
They're trying to destroy her head in hand so we only have legs to like pull
big,
heavy rocks for the government.
Just don't get the need for another clock.
Like you've got to clock in that big thing in your pocket,
dummy.
Why is it attach to that stupid little thing on your wrist that you're not never
going to look at?
Maybe they want you to like keep because it's so big.
Keep the note like hidden waste.
You don't have to actually pull it out.
This big thing,
you know what I mean?
Like maybe,
but then I bet it's a cluster fuck trying to get it to answer on your phone or
your wrist or talking in your phone.
You look like an asshole.
Here's what apple it has to do.
Apple has to release an exact version of the note size,
like maybe even bigger.
You get crazier and then have the best watch known to man and release both of
them at the exact same time in three to four months and then they will have
destroyed.
They can't do that now though because they've been cock blocked.
Samsung put out those,
those two items together.
Apple could never just copy that,
put out their own phone and their own watch.
Supposedly that might be why they got rid of the old iPod.
Remember this square?
I thought that everyone was making watches.
They immediately changed it to an uglier longer one because they were like,
shit,
we don't want to destroy our own watch market.
Uh,
interesting.
Well they fucking,
they're too slow.
And I had to interview with Dave Foley,
this guy,
and he uses that.
Maybe he doesn't take fully for news radio.
Right,
right,
right.
All right.
So I talked to this other guy and he might use Foxcom and you would think that
that that product takes like,
you know,
weeks to make from like sending it,
it takes only days before,
like thousands and thousands of like units to be made.
That's how fast Fox is.
Like Fox comes a robot.
That's why those people were jumping off buildings.
Yes.
The,
the
death people.
Apparently there is,
um,
a new cell phone company out of the Netherlands that's calling itself the phone.
I think it's out of the Netherlands.
It's not available in the United States yet,
but it's all a ethically sourced minerals and uh,
people were paid a certain wage to make.
The phone doesn't have four g though.
It's got like three G.
It's not quite four G,
right?
Yeah.
So it's,
it's you,
you take a beating a little bit,
but it's Android,
it's an android phone and they're trying to make a phone that you could buy that
you don't feel like a piece of shit.
Like if you watch those vice documentaries and how they get the minerals in the
Congo and you go,
Whoa,
that's Kinda fucked.
Yeah.
That's going to be like the having the first at your wide,
you're going to have that phone in and it's going to be whack.
It's going to be whack anyway.
rogan.ting.com a Hulu plus.
We're also sponsored by Hulu plus,
which coincidentally Brian actually watched on his tank phone.
Crazy man park.
That's the beautiful thing about Hulu.
Pluses that you can watch TV shows on your IPAD,
you can watch them on your phone,
you can watch them on various tablets,
home computer as a tour.
Thousands of TV shows and a selection of a claimed movies on your TV or on the
go.
What's that sound?
Oh,
it's that commercial.
Hulu commercial commercial.
Yeah.
Look at that.
It's so awesome.
You could also check out exclusive content they have including Hulu originals,
like the awesomes,
starring Snls Seth Meyers and moon boy starring Chris O'Dowd from bridesmaids.
But if you're a dude and you know who was in bridesmaids,
how dare you.
That's what I said to you.
How dare you actually,
I heard it was a funny movie.
Was it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's good.
Uh,
Hulu plus also offers a great selection of acclaimed films for only seven 99,
$7 and 99 cents a month.
You can stream as many TV shows and movies as you want.
It's pretty sweet.
Go to Hulu plus.com forward slash Rogen and you could try it free for two weeks.
So that's Hulu plus.com forward slash.
Rogen.
This is a special offer to all my friends out there.
So go get the extended free trial and let us let them know.
What are you doing?
I'm looking at these high Asians that we're putting in this commercial.
You got to promise broken broken person.
Um,
anyway,
Hulu plus,
so the,
the uh,
website,
Hulu plus.com forward slash.
Rogen we're also bought to you by bought to Walsall ought to buy on a.com.
O.
N.
N I t.
Uh,
we have the new Zombie kettle bells that are in stock.
Now,
if you loved the prime of bells,
you will be love again with the Zombie Bells.
Same Dude made him Steven.
She wouldn't jr is bad ass artist who a Aubrey hired to make the chimpanzee,
the gorilla,
the ape,
the orangutan,
and the um,
uh,
monkey.
How are their monkey?
We also now have a 72 pound,
54 pound,
36 pounds and 18 pound Zombie kettlebells.
Note the lack of pools in the description as it should
be.
Saint the fucking 12 hundreds and Russia,
it just sounded Christ,
it sounded kind of like hipster.
Well,
it's just one of those things.
It's the kettle bell community.
They did love to use the word pooed.
You know,
like the,
they like to be silly.
You know,
like people love to do that.
I was at a gun store the other day and I heard people talking and like they all
do.
I lock the Ar with the five four and the people love to have like very like
inside dialogue to let you know they're,
they're on the cutting edge of this particular point of interest.
So when you talk about,
you know,
what do you,
what are you doing your training with?
Well,
use two pood you know,
it was much swings and I'm leaving the shut up.
Tell me pounds.
God dammit,
don't even go metric.
Don't you dare go metric.
Well,
34 kilogram.
Oh,
use 34 kilograms.
What country do you use that and fuck head.
Huh?
He goes straight to Russia with your kilograms.
You go to China.
This is America boy.
72 pounds.
Say a bitch.
That's what I'm saying.
Uh,
we also have,
uh,
some new supplements and including a one 80,
which is our response to one 80 is basically the best way you can nutritionally
try to satisfy a high,
a hangover or jet lag.
I want to put this to the test,
Joe.
Yeah,
I get fucked up.
You do anyway.
Just drink it.
No,
I mean take it sober and see if it gets me drunk.
it doesn't work that way.
You got to hit,
hit your head on something.
Um,
it's basically the neurotransmitter support of Alpha brain with the best
adaptive gins from shoon tech sport,
some five HTP in their minerals,
all sorts of wonderful nutrients.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com there's plenty of information on the various
ingredients and what they hope to achieve.
Really a fun stuff.
I,
I've been a fan of taking alpha brain after long plane flights and after,
um,
uh,
if I've had some alcoholic beverages,
either one of those things really can slow down your thinking.
And I think their nutrients are the things that sparked that backup,
especially nutrients specifically designed to improve cognitive function.
All of it is explained on,
on it.
Uh,
calm.
That's o.
N.
I.
G.
Joe.
Can I get a discount?
Uh,
an audit discount for whoever designs this website because I want to meet them
to my website.
Look at this shit like you scroll down in the ship.
Pores said it opens up.
Yeah,
the,
they're awesome.
But he finds great artists.
Man.
Arby's,
a smart cat on it.
O n n I t use the code.
Rogan save 10% off any and all supplements.
Justin Foster is here.
He is a young comedian.
He is from Texas and he's ready to get his free con.
It's a music.
Brian,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try by day Joe Rogan by night
all day.
Justin forced or from Texas.
He's a chameleon
that she should be a new intranet is.
Thank you very much.
The fuck credits dude.
Fuck all that.
Comedy central nonsense.
Just hit an mc a card with the song on it.
Just saying this bitch,
seeing it like your children are in trouble or I'm not doing the time.
Hit hit the high notes too.
Don't crackle.
Uh,
we met Justin when we were doing the Addison Improv couple of years ago.
Right?
Two,
three,
four years.
Longer than that.
It's like five or six.
It wasn't really,
yeah,
it's been awhile.
Damn time flies.
But he was a very funny then since then he's gone downhill.
You were,
I was,
it was a very fun to see that Texas,
especially Dallas and in that one club has like a real community.
Yeah.
We came in the first time we came in like we did a show before the show like Ari
and someone else was a part of it was Joey was it Joe?
Yeah.
Yeah that was um,
yeah,
you guys had a showcase night where there was like a gang of like local comics
went up and you went up and um,
who was the other cat that we were just talking about?
That one I told John told you went up and there was a few other ones but you had
like a real community.
Yeah.
Dallas to get a good,
a good comedy scene.
Yeah.
It was cool to know or cool to find out.
I didn't know before.
So yeah,
it's always nice to see like it's all you need is like one club where there's a
couple funny dudes they get together and then the open Mike night kind of kicks
ass every week.
People keep coming back.
All you have to do it.
But everybody's so short.
Shortsighted.
They don't do the open mikes anymore because open mikes don't make any money.
Right.
Nobody Britt.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a problem.
There's nobody really comes in for that because the headliner is coming to net
weekend.
Yeah.
So,
well,
it's not even that no one comes in for that.
The clubs,
the local clubs are missing out on an opportunity to raise local talent.
It'll save you money.
Like you don't have to pay for their hotel room.
They live nearby.
Right.
And it also will ensure that you always have a good show.
And you could start doing these shows on Tuesdays and Wednesdays.
Well,
you might be dark and you could make a lot of money doing that if you just had a
real local scene.
And that was the cool thing about that club.
And it's still like that.
But there'll be like,
if a headliner only wants to do two shows on Saturday,
they'll be like,
okay,
well we'll do an 1130 show,
but we'll give it to all the local guys.
Like nobody,
you know,
nobody does that anymore.
Smart people get off work.
Like say if you've got off work at 10 30 and he know that there's an 1130 show
like fucking man,
let's go to the Improv.
A couple of drinks is always a good show.
The local guys are always good.
Right?
You know,
there was this time in Boston where there were no visitors,
that everything was all handled locally.
It sounds crazy to people today,
but the only people that played that came in from out of town where like Jerry
Seinfeld would do a concert.
George Carlin would do a concert,
right?
But there was very few like comedians came in and did like a week at the club
and it was all by local
talent.
And because of that,
there was this amazing wealth of local talent and a place like Dallas is taking
that same concept,
you know,
that Addison Improv and they were just running with it.
Is it still like that now?
It's gotten better.
Now there's another club.
Uh,
there's two other clubs and there's like bar shows and there's like underground
shows and like it's,
it's a really cool scene now.
So important.
Every improv should have an open mic night.
Someone should just sit them down and said,
listen,
this is like you're planting a garden.
It might actually cost you money the first year because you've got to buy all
your seeds and your machinery and you might not,
it might be cheaper for you to go out and buy the food,
but don't do it.
Stick with it.
Cause if you stick with it,
you can have a real comedy scene and that you build a fan base.
And so when you've got a headline in that comes in that it's not necessarily
going to draw a lot of people.
You Go,
well I got two local guys who we've been developing for the last three years.
That'll help.
Yeah.
And they don't need a hotel room and there they will do it for nothing.
And you'll,
you'll educate people about comedy in general.
More people be aware of,
of good comedy.
Yeah.
When a scene develops like that,
it's such a cool fucking thing to watch.
Like Denver,
there's one Wendy in Denver who owns a comedy works.
She did it all on her own.
Like essentially she created the the Denver and cultivated the to Denver comedy
scene with those comedy works clubs.
She's got two of them there and she's got a whole system as far as like open
miker so they go from open mic to middle and middle act a headliner and the
cultivate these local people and they've been doing it forever and because of
that there's all these funny people like if you go to a sealed local show and
I'm like a Monday night or what have you.
It's a lot of funny comedians.
Yeah,
and Austin is the same way too.
Awesome.
Like if you go into the cap city on a on a Tuesday night,
it's always a really good show.
Awesome.
Yeah,
that's a perfect example because Austin is like a real hang too like comics.
Like whenever I'm in town,
I always see comics that are also in town,
like hanging out at the bar.
You know guys who are working at the Velveeta Room,
we'll come over or what have you.
Right.
You know,
it's,
there's clubs there like hangs.
We're comics,
we'll like meet up yet an Improv is good like that.
Edison,
there's a club called high end is in Dallas where they have a big bar area,
so the door,
the open mic and say they don't make a lot of money off ticket sales,
but now you've got 40 comics hanging out the bar till 2:00 AM you're going to
make,
you know what I mean?
You're going to make money.
Yeah,
no doubt.
And again,
it's,
it's one of those things where you can't look at it as a,
like a straight flat business move.
You have to look at it as a part of owning a business,
a part of owning a comedy club.
A critical part is supporting the community.
They fuck up with that.
These big giant places,
they don't have open Mike Nights.
It's,
it happens a lot now.
Much more so than what I was coming up,
but I was coming up.
It seemed like during the 80s,
comedy got so big and so crazy that everywhere you looked there was an open mic
night.
There was so many of them.
They were everywhere and every club had won.
Every club stitches had one.
Knicks had won all these different clubs in town,
had one.
And it was,
seemed like every time you would go local or you'd go to a,
um,
uh,
a road Gig,
the local comics would have an open mic night as well.
It was like to,
everyone always had one,
right?
It was a part of having a comedy club.
You had an open mic night and you would ask guys like,
when's your open mic night?
Oh,
we do Sunday nights.
we do Monday.
And it was just a standard thing.
But then they started creating these big monstrous fucking clubs that seat like,
like,
like standup live in Phoenix is 600 fucking people.
Hey,
San Jose improv palace.
Yeah.
That ancient Improv is the most beautiful old theater.
It's an amazing old theater.
The San Jose Improv.
You ever performed there?
That's,
I haven't done that.
Fuck.
That place is amazing.
Fuck,
it's so 20th are you?
Yeah.
It's so gorgeous.
It's just a beautiful,
beautiful old theater.
Like it has a feel to it.
Like when you're walking backstage,
like this place has been,
people have enjoyed things in this place for a long ass time,
but it's huge.
You know,
545 days.
Yeah.
Like the old Tempe Improv was like four 50 right?
Those about four 15 yeah.
Those places,
it's hard to do an open mic night when you get 459 people up front and a 450
yeah.
It's hard to also have the local headliner,
you know,
because you got 450 seats to fill.
You don't really take that chance.
You go with a,
you know,
whatever.
Rob Schneider,
you know,
whatever.
You know,
you go go with someone who has a name,
maybe over someone who's a local guy who would be maybe even funnier,
but it's,
people don't know about it.
I don't know who it is.
Right.
But in Boston,
they all knew about it.
Everybody knew about Lenny Clarke.
Like I remember when I was telling people that I was trying to be a stand up,
they would say,
oh,
you know,
I just taught Steve Sweeney last month.
You know,
everyone knew the local guys.
Right.
But Boston is like that with bands to like Boston supports local bands.
Like anybody that was like Boston,
that was big.
Always came back to boss like Aerosmith and there was celebrated.
You know Boston does have a good reason.
Yeah.
Boston had a great mood.
Music scene.
It's still does.
They have a lot of like clubs like by,
it's just a smart fucking town.
Too Bad.
It's cold as fuck.
I would totally live there if they could move Boston to Texas.
I had moved there and it sounds like a damn heartbeat.
You would,
you would move back to Boston if just the weather was a little bit better.
Yeah.
I would just live outside of town.
I wouldn't live in the city.
The city's too hostile.
We could get those voices of the women,
keep hearing them and you'll be at or like target and get to hear it.
It would keep my pants zipped up.
Bloody it,
Clia
deals.
There was a girl when that we've talked about this girl to the end of time when
we were at Boston,
she was just drunk and just yeah,
and the audience.
No,
she was,
it was outside after the show.
We were trying to get something to eat.
They had like this one of those,
uh,
you know,
street carts that serve like sausage sandwiches and stuff like that.
If we were all waiting around and this,
this chick was just so hammered and she said to me,
he think you're via fax.
And that's what started my hate for Boston women right there.
Just like the chick.
What does that movie with Christian Bale where he was like the crack head and
it's like the,
like the nine sisters.
My friend was having sex with a girl from Boston and while he was having sex
with her,
she goes,
Ganna tell your friend,
be out to dinner.
And he would just in the middle of doing it,
you can it tell you a friend.
It was just so drunk and exhausted and beaten by laggard while they're having
sex.
You can.
It's how you friends.
The girls that are from Boston that live here in La and know how to hide it very
well,
but then once in a while to snip out,
come out.
Oh yeah,
I knew it.
They get drunk and angry.
Right?
Fights.
That's like scratching you with their nails.
It isn't a market.
This Boston what?
Yeah,
it's the same.
something like that.
They call this the Boston man.
Come on,
man.
Whoa.
Jesus
market.
They have these coca cola machines.
Have you seen where it's like touch screen and you can be like,
yeah,
I'll have,
I'll have Mel yellow a zero.
They make mill yellow.
Zero.
What?
Grape mellow yellow,
zero flavor.
It's 500 flavors.
It's,
it's like,
it's like a formula that coke don't want,
doesn't want to spend the money to mass market because it's like,
I don't think that many people,
it's going to like it,
but they have now put it in one machine.
So you taste all these flavors that are unreleased.
Yeah,
I've tried.
I've done that in a movie theater.
Movie theaters have those,
you can add like a bunch of shit and some of the more sophisticated movie
theaters.
Yeah,
but I just go diet coke really cooks hero.
I want to take any chances to fuck anybody doing with coke zero to make it about
coke zero.
What's better for you?
Coax here.
I'll die there bro.
Fucking terrible for you.
Right?
Should be just,
should it be just drinking water?
You know how the,
the famous thing is that Mexican cokes use real sugar about to change that and
you do it the American Formula Way,
God dammit,
because just a couple of Mexican joints in La that I go to just because they
have those bottled cokes from Mexico that have real sugar on them.
Real cane sugar or such concert.
We ruin everything.
They're just not fat enough.
People aren't bad enough.
They want to add more corn.
Sherp Mexicans were just coming out a little too lean.
We need to add corn syrup.
I'm up there.
Probably made some horrible deals.
Some core manufacturer,
some giant conglomerate,
right?
Yeah.
Somebody should step up and make a like a sugar cane sugar soda.
That sounds bad for you.
That's probably all justice as anyway.
I just had a Stevia,
uh,
based Cola that I bought at trader Joe's.
What,
what are the horrible,
it's you know what it tastes like,
like shitty generic coke.
Cause you know,
coke and Pepsi have a flavor and that's why they're famous and you don't get
like an RSC and you're like,
well this was like generic cola.
But then like as if it was sitting out opened in the frigerator for three weeks
and then shut back up,
you know,
right
off Stevia is horrible.
Yeah.
Tab.
Well coke,
coke,
Coca Cola actually uses cocaine and you know,
that's not a reason that that was a real,
is that real?
It's not a myth at all.
They use the coca leaves and the actual company that extracts the cocaine from
the coca leaves that they use to make coke.
There's no cocaine and Coke Cola.
Right.
But there used to be,
but the flavor is still the same because of the fact that they used this stuff.
What do you do?
What are you showing me?
This is an old tab.
Commercial at base was based on conspiracy theories for tab.
Cool.
Really?
It had a big,
that's the tabs after my own heart.
A big foot.
Yeah.
Hmm.
That's a tab commercial.
Yeah.
Um,
nothing screams,
soda pop conspiracy theories.
Where was I?
I'm thirsty.
What was I talking about?
Cocaine.
Oh,
so the,
the largest medical manufacturer of cocaine is actually connected directly to
Coca Cola.
They take their,
their cocoa leaves,
they extract cocaine out of it.
They use it for medical cocaine.
And then coke uses those cocoa leaves without the cocaine in it.
For Flavor.
Really?
Yeah.
They've done it forever.
That's why Coca Cola is a very unique flavor.
If you compare it to Pepsi,
Pepsi can suck it.
How about that?
Not as good.
Nope.
It's not as good.
Coca Cola was the original one.
They have the original cocaine flavor and look,
there's something to that flavor that's,
it's a little bit Tangier,
a little here,
so something to it.
Pepsi's like Pepsi's like a girl who didn't need to get a nose job but got one
anyway.
Why'd you do that?
I said to people to eventually be a commercial for coke right there.
Sweet.
Somebody from the Coca Cola company.
Just a guy going,
yeah.
We used to put coke in this.
Not that I wouldn't drink Pepsi in a heartbeat or Diet Pepsi.
I don't avoid it.
I just preferred diet coke.
Yup.
Sanford,
Texas.
Dr Pepper.
Dr Pepper is much better than both of them.
How about that?
How about Root Beers?
The shit over there.
Fuck yeah man.
What does that one kind of root beer that you always get?
Like the really Nice Delis.
It's in like the old school Lee fucking like Abbott brothers bottle barks.
ABC.
Yeah,
that stuff's that shit.
They make a diet.
Root Beer.
That doesn't even make you feel like a pussy.
It feels good.
The actual one though,
if you can act,
you know,
I've been gluten free for a while,
but if,
if I really decided to go on a bender,
I'm going to go that caviar Rita's and get a sausage sub with a fucking real
root beer.
We just feel it.
You feel the whole thing.
Why don't they use IBC?
What did they use?
It's IBC,
right?
What do they use in there?
Let's see in groups and watch it be beer pecking the day they used to actually
be,
was it fun or back of the day?
Cookies had coke and root beer used to be bare and heroin used to be illegal.
Molly,
Molly butter was actually a really good time.
I'll leave butter.
There was no Molly butter,
right Molly?
When did they,
when did they discover Molly?
I Dunno.
Is it Molly?
Just ecstasy.
Okay.
They have corn syrup in this shit.
IBC root beer though.
Delicious has high fructose corn syrup.
So I think they all do,
man.
Yeah.
I don't think anybody rocks a soda with sugar anymore.
But New York Seltzer,
whatever happened to this guy,
that root beer.
It was kinda weird.
New York Seltzer roofing.
What was that?
Cherry coke.
Dr Something.
Oh,
Cherry Cola doctor.
And he would uh,
make a root beer.
Dr Solace.
Cause that would be gross shawls.
Cherry Cola.
I just type Dr. Cherry Cola.
Dr Pepper.
There was like,
you know,
it was,
it was another Delhi one.
I'll give you went to a lot of delis.
Velocity.
That's a term you guys have life off.
Hold what you sound like Woody Allen outcome.
Yeah.
That doesn't sound like it at all.
No,
it's not clearly Canadian
doctors something.
You just name it shit.
Now Mr Thunder doctor beverage.
Is it doctor or Mister?
I don't know.
Mister Pib.
No,
that's,
no,
that's a Dr Pepper.
No soft Dr One.
Isn't there a doctor one?
I don't know.
What the fuck do I know Jack to keeps pulling me.
Dr Pepper.
Dr Soda.
Oh,
you make it shut up.
That's it.
That's the one.
Talk to me making shit up now.
Well,
this Austin is one of the few places that has uh,
like places where people will wait in line for hours and hours and hours.
Austin has that one.
Um,
a barbecue place.
What is it called?
DUBBS.
No.
Franklins or something like that.
What is the new one?
There's a new crazy barbecue place in Austin.
Fear just went there and told me it's worth it.
Is it the place that looks like it looks like a house,
but there's like a line going down the street just to wait.
Probably literally somebody's house.
I fucking love Texas.
Do you Miss Texas living out here in la or did you do I do,
yeah.
Like I said,
I fought living here like the first year.
Franklin barbecue and now,
yeah,
now I had joined in barbecue,
Franklin Barbecue.
This is the spot.
If you go there and pack a lunch,
get there early to take you hours.
You gotta wait in line.
And Ari was like,
how could this possibly be worth it?
And then he said,
he sat down,
he was like,
oh my God,
it's worth it.
Really.
How long did he wait?
More than an hour.
Huh?
That's like standing outside for an hour like an asshole in the middle of the
summer.
I think he was there for south by southwest,
but Anthony Bordain waited in line to on his TV show.
He did the whole deal.
Like everybody else waited in line pointing out the front.
He didn't want to,
he wanted the full experience.
That's the experience.
Your experiences,
not just eating.
If there's a place that always has a line,
the experience is waiting in line.
Right?
Like I was just in Nashville and they have some place that on Sunday morning,
it's some pancakes spot.
You fucking can't get in there.
There's a giant line that last an hours.
People get there early and they wait for a guy with a clipboard to get the
pancakes.
Oh,
I thought you said,
is there a missed?
Like you couldn't see it.
You're like,
I can't get into that.
A giant fog.
Where would you think miss?
I thought he said line line line.
You think list would go with line.
You know what this restaurant needs no machine or something about missed a
magic.
Maybe.
Maybe it's magic that you could make these people waiting in line for fucking
pancake check.
So wizard,
check this place out.
Yeah,
that looks so delicious.
That's what I miss about living out here.
Cause they always had these Texas barbecue places out here and you get there and
it's never as,
oh,
let me fix you up real quick.
Hughley Walkleys van eyes hardly walk.
God Damn Dude.
It's one of the best barbecue places on the planet earth and it's here.
Fuck yeah,
he never been a doctor.
Hughley Walkleys Oh,
I went there yesterday,
son.
Really incredible artists in a very shady neighborhood.
But if you're the Compton to get barbecue,
it is git as all.
Fuck.
Hughley Walkleys is the bomb.
Diggity dude,
you'll eat there.
The ribs,
the brisket,
the fucking everything.
Their French fries are legit.
It's so good.
It's without a doubt.
The best barbecue in all of Los Angeles.
Fact it's fucking outstanding.
They have like the bread,
it's sweet.
And when you're eating the barbecue,
like with the bread,
it's like,
oh my Christ.
They have buckets of sauce.
They leave on the table.
Hot,
mild.
Oh my God.
It's so good.
All right.
That place is super legit and the decor hasn't changed.
It's like 1953 but is there missed is they're mysterious.
There's missing your eyes when you're eating because you're crying cause he
can't believe how good it is.
I drove to uh,
Bledsoe's and Compton.
They had pretty good barbecue but yeah.
BLEDSOE's and Compton.
Yeah.
It's always good to have barbecue and there's bars on the windows of the
restaurant.
We want them going where you live.
Yeah.
I think that uh,
there's some places that you have to go to for the food.
Have you done a chicken and waffles yet at Rose Dance?
Yeah,
I did Roscoe to go there and I did pink.
I stood in line for an hour for fucking hot.
That's nonsense is nonsense.
Pinks is a trick.
Yeah.
That doesn't make any sense.
Grounds Dr. Brown.
That's what it was,
doctor.
Yes,
because they have cream soda and the Cherry Soda to pinks is just a regular hot
dog.
It's just a hot dog.
This is not even like a super gourmet like butcher shop hot dog where they snap
when you bite into them.
They're not even that.
They're just regular hot dog.
It's at sheep mentality though is when people see a line,
they go,
oh,
he's got to do this.
I drove by it the other day.
There was only like two people in line.
Never saw that before.
I'm like I two p people.
That's how entourage did six seasons.
Right?
So same thing like the shitty club when they make everybody stand outside before
they opened to think that,
oh this is cool and there's nobody inside.
It's a smart move.
Make everybody stand outside.
Right?
And then you let them through and they just run it and they go,
Hey,
wait,
what the thing would say when six flags opens,
go charging into this empty hall.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's,
there's some spots that are worth traveling to Roscoe's chicken and waffles
without a doubt
is one.
And that's another one.
If I ever go off the gluten diet,
Ooh boy am I gonna fuck up some chicken and waffles.
Who would have ever thought that would be an amazing combination,
but it's perfect.
I recommend Dominic's by the Beverly Center.
Um,
Delmonico's pizza,
uh,
on Fairfax right across the street from another awesome place.
Canter's Deli,
canter's Deli,
best Pastrami in all of Los Angeles.
Best people will just be to really,
you liked it?
Let me just looking around who it goes there.
You know your three in the morning and it places pack with crazies run into
comics there all the time that Reagan was there yet.
I'm always running into people.
That last time I was there running into Marin and I've run into Jeff Ross there.
I ran into everybody there.
It's like,
it's one of those spots where it's between the comedy store and the Improv so
it's like it's a straight shot to go down there and get it animal.
Have you been an animal?
It's right next door to that.
Somebody was telling me about that place so you would love,
it's one of those like,
oh I think on eat bone marrow I want to eat at like a pig's butthole,
whatever you want to eat.
Like any part of the animal.
It's really any part of the animals must be really good though,
right?
Not everyone,
every part,
but it seems like the usual things you're saying brains and stuff.
Oh really?
It's animal and Los Angeles right down the street from it was actually just tell
me about that then today.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Yeah,
I've heard of that many times.
That place.
Um,
I've heard it from you at least twice.
Yeah.
I think someone should be opening up a game restaurant in Los Angeles and I was
like,
I know that place here in Calabasas,
you know that w there's,
that's nowhere near here.
But yeah,
that's the,
it's called the um,
uh,
the something lodge saddle peak locks.
Saddle peak lodge.
Yeah.
It's like on the way over to Malibu.
People would freak out out here though.
If you opened it like a wild getting like I could just see people like picketing
it hides in the mountains.
You know,
there's a point in saying that it's not good because you don't want like factory
farming of these wild animals you want it to be.
But if you could have like a small restaurant that didn't serve that many people
and it was hard to get in and it would be fucking bad ass if you knew that.
Like if like say my friend Steve Rinella,
he's a hunter and he has that show meat eater and I went hunting with him and I
got this deer right here.
If he had his own restaurant and it was all just stuff that he shot,
he shot like a new animal every week and cooked it in the restaurant and you
only ate like what they had shot recently.
That would be amazing.
That would,
if someone did that,
like called it the hunters lodge and have,
you know,
only have like 10 seats or 20 seats,
a small place,
there'd be a line out front and you just have it so that these people have like
some sort of sustained,
like there's a lot of places in Texas where they have what they call high fence
operation where they're essentially wild animals,
but they're blocked in,
they can't go anywhere.
And so because of that,
they're allowed to control the populations and there's more wild game species
from Africa in Texas than are in Africa.
A lot of different species of antelopes and all sorts of different animals that
are extinct in India.
But I have great numbers in Texas because these guys create these wild wild game
parks and then you take these these places and they set up tree stands and some
of them are like real blatant,
like they have feeders and if 6:00 AM every morning food comes out so the
animals just gather up and you blast away.
I mean you could do it that way or you could try to do it more ethically.
We try to stock these animals in their natural habitat,
but for the most part you're talking about places with like huge amount of
acreages.
Someone,
some of them have two,
three and more thousand acres.
So they're huge.
So it's conceivable these animals never even seen a person before.
They're all fenced in.
And if you had something like that and cultivated the animals that way,
you have like a sniper who works for you.
And then he just takes out an a an animal every day.
And you,
you know,
today we're having bison that was just killed three hours ago by our hunting
team.
I mean that would be incredible if people could see how delicious and how good
for you that kind of food is.
We would really start relooking at the American diet.
I've noticed a big difference in like I get as much as I can.
I try to buy grass fed beef now and I,
whenever I have a state that's not grass fed,
I notice it in the taste.
I noticed it in like what it looks like.
It looks Pale.
Like if you have like a grass fed piece of meat,
it's a dark red,
it's a different color.
Right.
And if you buy one that's,
that's corn fed,
it's like this poor thing is anemic.
Yeah.
And you also feel different to when you eat,
you know,
like if you eat organic chicken and then you'd go back to eating like process,
you can definitely tell the difference and like just how you feel afterwards.
So I've never been able to tell the difference in chicken.
I can't.
Organic chicken.
And then you go back to the process.
Always.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well maybe you're more sensitive to that than I am,
but I think there's been a lot of research that's been done on like what's
healthy for you?
What kind of lean protein,
what,
what kind of a diet the animal should be on or to optimize nutrition value of
the food.
The best is wild.
That's the best.
They're the leanest animals.
Their fat is the most valuable.
Like bears like bear fat.
They've render that down and make these big jars of it and cook with it.
It's amazing stuff,
especially if the bears had been eating like blueberries and actually has almost
a blueberry tint to it.
It's incredible.
It's like very highly valued bear fat.
When they blueberries,
you can catch a bear that's been like dieting off nothing but blueberries from
months.
Oh my God.
It's the most amazing meat ever.
The meat's delicious though.
The fat is to,
and it's just so much more ethical than stuffing them into these farms where
they're all blocked in and they can't even move.
And they fill them full of fucking fatty foods and then pissed in through the
brain,
drain them out.
And you know,
they never had a life.
These animals live like a wild animal.
They're running around out there eating grass,
eating the,
the natural plants that they would eat and then you shoot him.
It's totally a better move.
I support it.
I'm down.
I'm just saying you just got so hungry for eight brains,
Joe and you have had brains.
What's that like?
What's it,
it's kind
of like,
like a scrambled eggs type feel.
Brains was texture to it.
I've had lambs brains.
My uncle used to cook lambs brains on the,
on the grill.
Really?
Yeah.
It was,
uh,
in the 1970s,
I guess this was around.
I was a really small boy,
but I remember I was always in the horror movies and weird shit.
And so he,
you know,
wanted to freak me out and show me their lamb skull and that we're going to cook
the lambs brain.
My uncle.
Very cool.
And uh,
I remember they,
they spiced it a certain way and would cook this lambs brain in the skull.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It was really odd.
I had never had it since then,
for a long time
time.
And then I had it long time ago at a restaurant,
there was a restaurant that has it served lambs brains.
And I remember I had that.
And I've also had sweetbreads,
which is some gland.
It's one of the gland of a,
I think it's a cow.
Well,
shit,
your uncle is not at,
which is fucking with it.
This is a sweet bread.
Try this.
Well,
you know,
my family,
my family's straight from the boat.
Everyone was straight from the boat.
My grandmother and my grandfather on both sides,
they're both,
uh,
my grandfather on my father's side came straight from Ireland.
My grandmother came from Italy and my,
both my grandparents on my mom's side came from Italy.
So they,
these motherfuckers,
they did everything right.
They killed their own rabbits,
you know,
they,
they ate everything.
So sweetbreads is a,
it's a parotid gland,
including the parotid gland,
the sublingual glands.
It's a bunch of different glands.
How do they prepare it?
Uh,
I think they fry it.
Okay.
I think they,
they,
uh,
it's like they pan fried frying makes everything.
Okay.
Here's one.
It says one common preparation sweetbreads includes soaking in saltwater and
then poaching in milk after which the outer membrane is removed.
Oh,
okay.
Once dried and chilled,
they are offering breaded and fried.
Okay.
So this is a lot going on with these things.
She,
that's when people needed food so bad.
They,
they tried to figure out how to eat everything.
Right.
You know,
they boiled down tendons and shit.
That's why they figured out stews.
Stews were for parts of animal that you couldn't eat.
Like you couldn't choke it down.
So He'd have to break it down with a,
with a brace.
He would braise them and then boil them slowly for hours and hours until the
meat finally gave up and collapsed.
If you're a caveman,
didn't know anything about eating animals,
eating meat and stuff like that and you were just put onto this earth and you
had to go,
all right,
I need to eat.
What would I start with first?
Would you go right to animal?
Cause I think I would just go grab a lot of grass and trees and stuff.
They were going to say people for a second problem
as you need fat,
you know,
especially if you don't have clothes and you're freezing your ass off,
you're going to need a lot of fat.
You're going to be fat period.
Like fat as energy,
especially if you don't have carbohydrates and you're not really going to get
the kind of carbohydrates that we get today with pastas and breads and you know
the standard wheat based carbohydrates.
So like the amount of calories that you would actually need from vegetables.
It's a pretty substantial like pounds,
right?
If you were just eating grass,
he would have to eat
la.
I would live in a forest or something.
I think I would start off with that with so when I'm saying like I be eating
like mud.
I think back then you'd have like two days a big now fuck this,
I'm going to kill something.
Starve to death dude.
You really would.
That's what I mean.
I mean if you tried to go vegetables only unless you have a garden man fucking,
unless you live in a really unique place where they have a lot of naturally
growing things and you can eat,
you got to cultivate your own shit.
It's,
it's hard to find.
I mean they are like edible roots is a lot of different things that are like
almost like wild potatoes.
He can eat their roots and they're very nutritious and there's a bunch of plants
you can eat but,
but getting enough of them and then also being aware of what you can and can't
eat this some shit that looks like shit.
You can eat it.
It'll kill you instantly.
Especially mushrooms when you start fucking around with mushrooms and picking
mushrooms.
There was a sad story recently.
This old lady in a nursing home went out and pick some mushrooms and cooked them
up for everybody that she lived with and they all fucking died.
Like I saw some mushrooms in my front yard today.
Like those big white ones that almost looked like call it.
The answer's no,
don't eat them.
Slick them first and then take a bite and then take two bites,
whatever you're about to say.
The answer's no.
Yeah,
I just know what those are.
Those kinds of mushrooms.
I always wondered if those were poisons cause you see those everywhere.
Yeah,
I would imagine they probably are.
I mean some of them are edible.
There's places like the Pacific northwest where people go mushroom hunting and
they're confident enough like there's some mushroom
that are so easy to poke out or point out rather that you can,
you can go,
okay this one we can eat.
It doesn't look very any other,
anything you can eat.
And there's a few that are like that and people grow them too.
They love to grow like shit.
Talkies and shit.
I did it once.
There's like a kit you buy at the supermarket and you basically just like put
some water on her or something like that and leave it somewhere and they start
growing.
I mean they want to grow,
they just this pretty easy to make a mushroom grow.
They grow quick too,
like a lot of feces and that helps.
It's the,
it's not just shit though it,
it has to be shipped from a cow and it has to be the way a double double
stomached animal eats.
They,
they,
they're shit like comes out like nice and like loose and it's got a lot of air
in it.
Like an alcoholic shit.
You can't have alcohol and they wouldn't grow well and alcohol and just a human
diet is no good.
It's not going to grow and meet.
It wants to grow in plants that had been smashed up and pass through the stomach
of,
I think it's called a double on [inaudible] animal or on Yulin animal.
These wild cows and that's the whole idea with the silicide button mushrooms,
they always grow and cow shit.
These big fucking huge plate size mushrooms will glow in the Amazon on cow shit
and they look like Ufo is landing in a field.
Right.
That's one of the reasons why the uh,
the idea came to a lot of people's heads that really tripped hard was that they
were communicating with another life form that came here and an asteroid.
I can tell
what makes sense at the time.
It doesn't just make sense
time unfortunately.
It makes sense like chemically.
Yeah cause spores can survive in a vacuum and apparently the chemical
composition of Siliciden is very unique and there's nothing,
there's nothing quite like,
it's like for Fox for Luxy and end dimethyltryptamine I know I said that wrong,
but whatever it is,
I was listening to a lecture once by turns,
but Ken and he was saying that the,
there's no other plant like that that has the phosphorous and the four position
and then it's really possible that it could have come on an asteroid from
another planet.
It's spores survive in a vacuum.
Apparently you could take some mushroom spores.
Like it doesn't have to be psychedelic Shataki,
whatever.
Put Him on a fucking asteroid shooting in a space and they'll live,
they'll land somewhere,
boom and make a little mushroom farm.
Do you see that asteroid or whatever the fuck it was over La the other day?
Yeah.
What was that supposed to be?
Did they say it was a satellite coming in then they say it was a satellite
burning up?
No,
I don't think so.
Last I heard it was a,
they said it was an asteroid.
Yeah,
that's what they said.
All these people were coming in like comics and stuff like,
man,
we just saw some crazy,
it was like a fireball coming right over us.
And I'm like,
oh no,
it's,
have you checked Twitter yet?
He's like,
no,
you mean I wasn't the only one that's solid.
And then on Twitter it's just,
cause I just like moving to la like a year and like I see Sheila and I don't
even know what's really,
you know,
like I saw an explosion the other day and I'm like,
I don't know if I should call anybody or if they're just filming a movie.
And so like you see shit fall from the sky like,
oh fuck,
I know what that is.
This animal plays doesn't even have a sign.
They have no sign in front of the restaurant.
I know.
Try to be slick.
You just have to walk you bitch.
They have chicken liver toast,
spicy beef tendon chip.
Yeah,
they got weird shit.
Pigtails,
pig years,
heirloom tomatoes,
veal brains.
Dude,
this makes places make me hungry.
Crispy pig head.
I'm in veal tongue,
charred octopus.
This place might be the greatest.
The history,
the war.
I'm telling you man,
it's my favorite wrestler.
Fried rabbit legs.
Oh my God,
this is incredible.
It's great.
And they're really nice people over there to that saddle peak lodge.
If you've never been there,
that place is the shit they serve like elk and venison and duck and they serve a
game game food.
But I think that would be like the ultimate restaurant.
That'd be like the ultimate community where you,
you lived with a bunch of people that see like I watched these Alaska shows like
I love like um,
life below zero.
You ever seen that one?
It's great.
It's new show.
I'm watching,
I think it's on the history channel or,
or no,
Nat Geo and they uh,
they go out and most of these people are just living off the land.
They're just out shooting seals and shooting Caribou and they barter,
they give each other stuff like the gate,
like they were traded in frozen fish for fucking seal oil and they dip their
food and seal.
It's,
it's craziness.
But what's fascinating is no one ever goes to the supermarket,
all their food,
they either grow or they kill everything.
Everybody in the whole village and they all share.
They like,
they have meals together,
they barter,
they give each other like,
I'll give you some Caribou,
you give me some of this and the,
I need a,
a band for my,
a snow mobile.
One of the guys blew one of his belts and the other guy gave him a snowmobile
belt that he gave him like a side of Caribou.
And it's like a lot of work,
too lazy.
Like I can't go grocery shopping.
It's a lot of work.
But like I literally made a sandwich like the last piece of the toast the other
day,
like the last piece of bread,
like I couldn't go kill a care about could you could though if you start that,
if you needed food you could do it.
I had cereal with water,
water powder crumbs from the end of the box works with certain cereals.
That's not bad.
Oh.
Chocula I can't even go get more lucky charms.
I'm going to go shoot a salmon.
You have something like count Chocula
coating on the outside of it and you'd see all that water would work.
Do you ever have um,
raw milk?
No.
I've used milk.
That was really questionable though.
I don't want to go get [inaudible].
It's not the same.
This is probably bad,
but you know what?
The Grocery store as a battlefield yogurt comes from though,
right?
It and I eat so much yogurt and that you just found that out.
We use,
well,
I'm not a smart man from a yogurt tree.
This body or exactly.
Did you grow up in Texas?
They have,
well,
we didn't eat yogurt.
They're wild pigs.
No Yogurt.
Yogurt,
yogurt.
It's just some board Dick on toast
that was watching this special episode of meaty to the other day.
We was cooking up dear balls,
talking about people always throw them away and you really shouldn't.
It's a waste of the deer ball.
So he's pan frying these deer balls and slicing them up.
Apparently they're quite delicious.
What'd you say?
What'd you try?
I'd eat it.
Hosted fear factor for sick.
He can't freak me out when it comes to food.
Very different sense of what's gross.
I,
this girl
puked in front of me,
the Trashcan,
I need a trashcan.
So I ran and grabbed her a trashcan.
We had both been drinking a lot of patrol and uh,
I gave it to her,
she pukes and we had Mexican before and it smelled like Mexican and vomit on it.
Get it away from me.
It smells.
And I'm like,
I started puking and she was like,
I need it back.
And it was just like South Park and just thought that what a story began.
So this girl threw up in front of me the other day.
Brian's living,
by the way,
he's 40.
Yeah.
There's something about puked.
It makes you want to Puke to instinct has totally been removed from me really
because of the show.
Yeah.
I saw so many people throw up.
It doesn't do anything to me.
It doesn't make me flinch.
When I was a kid,
I was the first guy.
If,
if someone threw up in the hallway,
I was the first guy to start dry heaving.
I owed,
I threw up the first season of fear factor.
I threw up watching it on TV.
I've watched the something that was there for in real life and I didn't throw
up,
but watching on TV I threw up.
But then by the time like season two to season three rolled around,
dude,
I was an Oji.
How's a veteran?
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I've,
I've cleaned people's puke up for them.
I think
that'll get drinking that stuff.
We'll get ya.
Your body realizes you've taken away too much poison too quickly,
right.
You're not sipping,
slamming it down and it's strong as fuck.
And next thing you know,
you're,
I vision's not good and you start,
your mouth gets dry and can't stay stable.
Sweating,
wobbling from side to side.
What do you two fucks over there and then trying to get me in trouble.
What are you doing Jamie?
What?
It's,
it's the two girls.
Oh yeah.
I had to turn away from that three times.
I almost threw up.
We don't have to watch it.
I almost threw up watching you watch that.
Yeah.
It was rough.
That was a,
that was people like did you guys stage that?
Absolutely not.
You can't pick both of them were real.
That was real.
And then the Brian Watching dudes cut their ticks so much worse.
I would agree.
I would agree with that.
Correct?
Yeah.
Getting your Dick cut off is always a bad move.
You notice that there hasn't been a shocking video in a while.
Like a Oh yes sir.
Is you just don't look,
I mean,
I mean minus beheadings cause I don't know if you've heard the whole Facebook
beheading drama that's been going on,
but uh,
that,
that was fucked up like a girl getting her head chopped off because she cheated
on her.
I saw that you watch that was the Mexican drug cartel videos or intense man.
They just,
they don't put on my Facebook.
Oh yeah.
People will throw a link up.
It's one of those things where people just start talking about it and you'd get
it,
you know?
And my Twitter has 1.1 7 million people or some shit like that.
So when you have that many,
they know,
they know what I like.
They know I like watching fucked up things.
I don't like the violence and death stuff.
It's like,
but every now and then I watched,
I like watching someone do something retarded.
You walk me through what happens in that video because obviously I'm not
watching that.
You don't want to watch it,
but it's rough.
We say noises,
which are gurgling.
It's shockingly quiet,
but it's intense and it's 100% real.
Oh yeah,
there's no doubt about it.
They cut this woman's head clean off.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
he did it with those a small knife.
He just reached into her neck and started cutting,
grabbed her by her.
I mean it was hardcore man and,
and it didn't take long.
You know,
her,
her head was removed and you know,
a minute or so I'm not.
Yeah,
it's hard.
It's hard to watch man.
And there's a lot of these videos too.
There's not just one of these videos,
these drug cartel videos,
man,
they never even existed before.
It was,
it's so crazy like climate of Mexico
and how much has changed and that you could see it all documented on some of
these videos and it's moving up here to la man.
You see that?
It is.
I think so.
I am so much crazy shit going on in la.
Our friend Kayla,
you know Kayla from dysentery,
somebody hit her car I yesterday or two days ago and it took off and so she went
on this high speed chase throughout Hollywood going wrong ways in streets going
like,
you know,
just chasing this person down and take a photo of it.
And then Mike,
it was just gang members pretty much in a new car,
you know,
and they finally got him over and they got out of the car and took a picture of
the person and the license plate and maybe some drama happened and then drove
off again.
And then they went down this dark street in a like a warehouse in like really
shady neighborhood and Kelly's like,
I'm done.
I'm not going down there.
But it was just like,
what could have happened to her?
And she went down [inaudible] supposed to chase people anyway.
If your car is good enough to drive,
that means you didn't get hit enough hard enough.
So you'd be chasing somebody that's ridiculous.
Like what are you trying to do trying to get yourself killed.
She wanted to get the license plates,
but the police,
she called the police immediately and tell them what direction where they're at.
You'd be amazed at how many cops were out there and a lot of times they can head
someone off,
especially if someone's driving fast,
you know,
they were on the phone with the police the whole time.
Oh.
But uh,
they got the license plate,
but that's it.
Uh,
there was one point though,
I guess they were going faster than the sky was going like 80 miles an hour.
I went over one of those like little hill things and the guy flew up and they
like four feet and came down just like,
oh,
it's fine.
Like sparks and fire came.
Wow.
Yeah,
dude thought he was on the Dukes of Hazzard.
Know I got robbed.
My friend Justin Martindale got robbed.
This place is crazy.
Well,
if you're out at night,
man,
that's the reality.
If you're out at night and you're wandering around,
especially if you've been drinking,
you know,
people look at you like you're a victim.
There's,
and there's,
when you have poor people and rich people all mingling together in Los Angeles
has a massive amount of people that are impoverished,
a massive amount.
There's 20 million people here who knows how many of them are living below the
poverty line.
It's a lot.
And if you're flossing and Hollywood and everyone knows where they can find you,
if you're some fucking baller character who's flashing some cash around in the
sky bar and people could find you in,
clock you and watch you and follow you to your car,
they're gonna rob you.
There's just a lot of that going on and it might happen only every now and
again.
It's amazing.
It doesn't have more than it does.
It's scary.
It is scary.
It's scary and it's an issue that our society doesn't face.
Our society doesn't face the fact that there's people that grow up with no shot.
They're fucked from the jump,
shitty roll,
the dice,
terrible hand being born and incredibly impoverished neighborhoods and there's
very little support there.
They're just left in their parents' hands and the parents are morons.
I mean that's,
that's the reality of babies growing up in poor neighborhoods.
Think of it like that because La is,
there's rich and poor like on top of each other.
Oh yeah.
Like each,
well not only that,
but disconnected from each other.
Right.
Where,
which is different than New York and New York,
poor people and rich people
all sort of mingled together on a subway mingle together,
walking down the street.
There's like a,
a more,
more human approach to like people being there.
It's more,
it's more diversified.
It's like you may run into everybody in New York,
like I find that it's easier to be in your own little world.
In La.
You get in your own little car,
you stay in your own little neighborhood.
You don't interact with people in New York,
you're forced to,
it's just a part of life in New York and I think that's a healthier thing.
I think it's healthier.
People have less fear of each other.
People you know and understand that we have much more in common that way.
It seems like it'd be a contradiction because most people think that Los Angeles
or California in general is nicer than New York,
but I think a lot of that is just the weather.
The weather here is nice as is humanly possible.
It's did.
I was just in Edmonton.
It was fucking nine degrees.
It was snowing.
It was an amazing show.
Had a great time.
Came back to la 84 bitch,
suck upon it.
At the end of November,
convertible driving attitudes are driving more variables with their sunglasses
on,
getting head cancer smiling.
Oh yeah.
It's amazing.
This is an amazing spot and I think just that alone is responsible for a lot of
the mood of the people in Los Angeles.
I think that alone helps a lot.
Yeah.
It's hard to be depressed when you go outside and the weather is absolutely
perfect.
Yeah,
but then you get a call from an agent saying they passed again.
Right,
and you're like,
fuck Ruth and the toilet.
It's a lot of depression in la because of just ridiculous expectations.
That's what I'm saying.
Like if the weather was worse here with the desperation in this town,
there would be a lot.
It would be a like a lot more.
I know a girl that moved out here just recently and when I first met her,
everything was going great.
Lost her job.
Now she's homeless and cold on the streets in Hollywood.
Where she,
how long she been down here?
What did she do wrong?
Um,
she just lost her job and then she couldn't get another job.
And then,
you know,
once you're out of money or how to money,
it doesn't have any friends.
So she just found out she actually just moved out here.
Whoa.
Yeah,
it's pretty sad when she moved down here with $2.
I don't know.
I Dunno,
but it kicked her ass fast and you know,
you'd get these texts and you're just like,
oh Jesus.
Well,
I'm sorry to hear that.
Bolton.
There are certainly individual stories were horrible.
Shit happens to horrible people.
There's no doubt about that.
But it's also,
there's a lot of people that come down here and their ideas are really shitty.
Their plan is poor.
They don't have backups,
they're not willing to do certain things.
They don't,
they don't take the necessary steps in order to make sure that they're going to
be okay.
I know this dude came out here to try and be an actor.
He's been out here and he thought he was just immediately,
apparently he's talented and he thought he was just immediately going to just
start getting roles and basically be a working actor within like a year.
It's a year and a half and he hasn't gotten a single job and he's starting to
freak,
you know,
and he doesn't to work.
He wants
to somehow or another like feed himself as an actor and that's not going to
happen.
Right?
Like it's,
it's,
you might,
you might get a movie and you'd be fine and so,
but he keeps banking on this idea that he's going to eventually get a movie and
then all his bills are going to be paid.
Like wow.
Do you know how many of you there are out there?
Like zero job.
He has no job.
He's his job.
See that?
That's why I'm so glad I've been classically trained as a waiter and that's one
of the best skills that you can have.
Any city I can get a fucking job at Denny's if it came down right.
I could be,
I can,
I have a job skill that I know like being a blacksmith or some and,
and people that haven't been waiters before,
I don't know if they're scared to be a waiter,
but it really is the best fall back job you could possibly happen.
There's so many fucking restaurants that you can get a good job and make a
living.
You could actually,
you know,
do really well is a good waiter.
Is it easy to get a waiter job though?
I think it is.
It's just the quality of the restaurant,
you know,
like,
like yeah,
you could get a fucking job at Denny's and come in there and anytime you wanted
to problems cause I bartended for a year,
so I know that in no matter how bad it gets,
I can always bartend somewhere.
In some towns I'll always had like some backup plan,
right?
Because people are always going to want to get drunk,
you know,
plus probably a lot of drunk tricks.
Bus moves on you.
Are you kidding me?
They must bus moves.
It's the best when you work at a restaurant also,
you're always getting laid because he'd become friends and alcoholics with all
the other waiters and waitresses and talk shit about how horrible the day is.
Right.
And you're all off at two o'clock in the morning at the same time and you all go
to the ground.
Each Other?
Yeah.
Oh Dude.
We would live when that was bartending in Dallas,
we would,
we would just drive to Shreveport,
Shreveport,
Louisiana.
It was like just made $300 let's go across the border and gamble.
How far away is Louisiana for?
A couple hours.
That's it.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's the best.
Is it like a different world though?
It's sad.
Like take the coolness of Vegas and then,
and then like it's just,
yeah.
It's not like Reno if it got bit by a vampire.
Right.
Reno for that aids.
Yeah.
There's a few of those places that are like,
Whoa,
we did a bunch of early.
UFC is in those places.
A casino magic and shit like that.
I'm like,
1998 is fun.
When you're a kid,
you're like,
all I can go and drink under age and gamble.
You Windsor,
California or Canada?
Windsor.
Yeah.
That's where like the whole Midwest would all drive up as kids to oh,
that's and go to strip clubs.
I actually saw some of that when we were in,
um,
we're filming in Detroit.
There was,
they were talking about how people,
you can be only be 18 you can get across to Kennedy could drink and got to strip
clubs.
And just,
it was,
it was awesome because you know,
most,
you know,
they're trying to raise the smoking age in New York to 21 which makes us much
sense.
Why is that?
Even though it doesn't make sense.
No,
it does make sense.
Why isn't it?
Right.
That's so stupid.
It's just,
there's a real problem with cigarettes.
There's so fucking addictive.
It's so addictive and they're so terrible for you and even a guy like you who's
not,
you know you're not completely retarded,
but yet you can't stop going back to them.
Yeah,
I know I'm quitting soon.
Now me and Kaylee are going to quit.
Oh that's sweet.
Together together forever.
If you're going to quit,
why don't you just fucking get electronic cigarettes man.
It seems like that is the worst invention in the road.
I am so anti electronic cigarettes was that you see these kids that are the
kids,
you see these people with like these humongous who because of electronic
cigarettes and they sit there and suck on it like a tit all night long and
they're just getting so much nicotine that they're pretty much telling it their
body.
Like,
hey no,
I need to live on nicotine.
I need nicotine in my body all day long.
All Day.
Knight [inaudible] electronic cigarettes too accessible.
Cause like with a cigarette you get to go outside,
you got to go across the street,
you gotta find a lighter,
then you guys will get the eastern area.
It's just always there.
Always there.
And the people stuck on those things,
like it's seriously like a thumb.
I mean,
I've seen it.
Yeah.
Right.
But from what I understand,
it's not negative.
It's not bad for you.
It's making your body get fucking used to having that much nicotine in it.
Yeah.
But I don't take nicotine is what's wrong.
Nicotine's not really that bad for you.
From what I understand,
nicotine is actually a medicine and isn't a highly addictive.
Right.
I don't know if it's the nicotine necessarily that's really fucking like shit.
They put in 590 different chemicals,
but people are addicted to American spirit cigarettes and that the only thing in
there is tobacco.
Let's find out nicotine addiction.
Let's find out.
Oh look,
nicotine addiction and then we'll,
we'll electronic cigarettes.
Yeah.
Just to me it seems horrible.
I don't know man.
It seems like way better for you.
Yeah.
But you're going to have to do that for the rest of your life.
You always think I would be east cigarette,
but instead of just quitting is what I'm saying.
Yeah,
I understand that.
But if you're looking for a bridge between the two,
it seems like there'll be a way better mood and less nicotine is not addictive.
It seems like you're just getting,
your body used to weigh like larger amounts of a drug cause,
but like I said,
I don't think that a dick that nicotine is a real issue.
Yes.
Siri.
Yeah.
As nicotine dangerous is nicotine addictive?
Of course it's tight.
Right?
I found on the web.
Oh,
grocery shit.
Nicotine.
Um,
there's benefits.
Studies have focused on the benefits of nicotine,
nicotine therapy for adults with Adhd.
Wow.
So if you can't concentrate,
you can smoke,
you should smoke.
Well,
you know,
it's really interesting because Steven King said that that cigarettes,
like when he quit cigarettes,
that was one of the most profound effects on his writing,
that it really,
really slowed them down because cigarettes really made a synapses fire and he
felt like it made it more cause stimulant.
Right?
Yeah.
Shit,
I have ADHD.
Oh,
you definitely,
are you kidding?
So keep spoken.
You're fine.
Yeah.
Doctor says psychoactive effects nicotine's mood altering effects are different
by report particular,
it is both a stimulant and a relaxant.
First causing the release of glucose from the liver and Epi,
epipen,
epinephrine,
adrenaline from the adrenal Medulla.
It caused,
it causes sim stimulation,
users report feelings of relaxation,
sharpness,
calmness and alertness.
Like any stimulant it may,
it may vary.
Rarely cause the often uncomfortable neuro psychiatric effects of,
hmm.
How about this one?
A K a.
By reducing the appetite and raising the metabolism,
some smokers may lose weight as a consequence.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Okay.
So the medical uses,
there's a bunch of different medical uses.
Um,
primary therapy pdqs of nicotine is in treating nicotine dependence.
Duh.
So stupid.
It doesn't seem like nicotine.
It's something you should suck on all day long.
That's what I'm saying.
However,
in a few situations,
smoking has been observed to be a therapeutic value.
These are often referred to as smokers paradoxes.
And although in most cases the actual mechanism is understood only poorly or not
at all,
it is generally believed that the principal beneficial action is due to the
nicotine administered and that the administration of nicotine without smoking
may be as beneficial as smoking.
So there's certain things like it says for instance,
study suggest that smokers require less frequent repeated revascularization
after whoa percutaneous coronary intervention.
Not many people do that anymore.
That's what is that?
It's like an old dance.
The TVS with black and white.
No.
What the fuck that is risk of ulcerative colitis has been frequently shown to be
reduced by smokers because you,
you kind of smoke the inside of your lungs,
you may get tougher.
Thank his main diseases that way.
Yup.
Wow.
That's not true.
We get more oil.
Tobacco smoke is also been shown to contain compounds capable of inhibiting mano
aiming oxidase,
which is what you take when you make a Iowasca.
My domain,
monoamine oxidase is um,
what keeps DMT from becoming orally active.
That's why like if you eat like grass and things that have DMT and if you don't
just start tripping your balls off because of mano aiming oxidase.
So if it inhibits model Amy and oxidize,
that can act as a hallucinogen too.
If it's in like,
like harming.
If it's in like large doses,
I think it's close to close to like death doses.
It becomes a hallucinogen.
Have you tried the E-cigarette at all?
Yeah,
I think I tried one.
I tried one recently.
Um,
because I wanted to see like what kind of a stimulant it gives you and whether
or not it would crave it more.
I puffed it all the way to the Bray Improv.
Did it do,
did it do anything?
Yeah,
gave me a little jolt,
but you know,
it's not something I want to do on a regular basis.
It just wanting to experiment with it,
see what it was like.
It doesn't have the satisfied checking of littering,
you know,
just being a bad ass.
I spoke at [inaudible] Vegas the other day.
Somebody had an EU hookah,
which was really one of those big fat ones.
Yeah.
The big loan.
That's what Bobby Lee walks around with.
Bobby.
He's got a God damn garbage can he brings with him.
It's filled up with nicotine.
So our roller and like he's rolling his golf clubs around him and PJ boats just
sit there and it just looks like,
I just look over.
I'm like,
that's not good.
That's just not good.
Look at that.
Right.
But that's Bobby really,
you know,
he's like super indulgent.
This,
those funny guys,
man,
there's so many funny guys that are just super indulgent and they almost can't
help themselves.
There's this radio station and uh,
I believe Columbus,
Ohio that Bobby Lee was on recently and uh,
they had it video recorded video and he sat down on the couch and there was a
point where they were talking about another comedian.
Uh,
what's the One lady that really funny Chow with the tattoos?
Margaret Cho.
Margaret trail.
Uh,
Margaret Cho was there.
She took off all her clothes and they were talking to Bobby about that.
And Bobby's like,
Oh,
you know,
I can take off all my clothes.
So he takes off all his clothes and sits down on the couch,
which is white.
And then when he sat up and later and left,
he left the little Brown [inaudible] the radio station,
cut it out.
And it's,
oh gosh,
he's dirty little like an excuse,
like,
well you don't understand.
I had an omelet too,
just shit his pants right there on their couch.
Oh,
he's probably cutting little farts to,
yeah,
you'd probably cut down.
He didn't want to let anybody know.
You probably get it on purpose.
He's like,
who has a white couch?
Yeah.
If you know Bobby.
Okay.
Um,
e-cigarettes,
let's see if,
uh,
it makes sense that e-cigarettes healthier.
Oh,
it's definitely healthier.
I'm not saying it's healthy,
I'm just saying that the nicotine intake,
I believe when you have like when these big who,
cause it's probably just drowning you with way more nicotine than your USP,
but I don't know if it is healthier.
I don't mind.
Not by much.
I mean,
I've,
it just feels like something's missing when you smoking a cigarette.
It's like drinking like coke zero.
You know what?
Maybe just doesn't have that.
Yeah,
it's probably where I feel more than that.
Like I feel like it's,
this is not doing anything.
It doesn't feel like I have a straw.
I'm just going.
Hmm.
It says the one thing is the nicotine levels they're worried is the electronic
cigarette can contain as much nicotine as a regular cigarette or more and then
the amount of nicotine and electric cigarette delivers depends on the content of
the liquid nicotine cartridge installed it.
So they can choose cartridges containing nicotine in a range of strengths and
everyone goes for the strong ones too,
from cigarettes and you're sucking on that thing all day long and stuff.
Having a cigarette every like 1520 minutes or so.
Is there also cartridges that contain liquid without nicotine for users who want
the sensory experience of smoking without its
effect.
So that's like fakers that's like people weren't fake glasses when they say that
your first year,
like you're not really addicted to the nicotine,
you're addicted to the movement of putting the cigarette into your mouth a year,
a year,
six months,
something I rent.
Yeah,
I like that.
A year,
six months,
three months.
You're just addicted to doing that.
I read it somewhere or heard it or somebody else read it and they told him about
it.
Because when you drink,
you get drunk immediately.
The cigarette,
you don't really become addicted to it.
Nobody really liked.
No one starts liking nicotine the first time you smoked a cigarette.
Well,
it's a weird feeling.
I remember that I did a,
uh,
sketch wants with,
um,
Adam Ferrara and Kevin James.
We're doing this Improv Troupe,
this comedy club,
and I did the sketch and I was supposed to play this,
uh,
this like poet that like smoked a lot of cigarettes.
So smart,
like really outrageous person.
So I was smoking these cigarettes on the set of,
so I took Adam cigarettes and I was fucked up,
man.
I was really fucked up within like two cigarettes or three cigarettes.
My head was flying.
I was like,
my God,
I'm,
hi.
This is crazy.
Like,
I didn't know this gets you high.
It gets you some weird kind of high.
Yeah,
it does.
but it doesn't,
it doesn't seem to interrupt your motor skills.
This is a,
by the way,
I don't know if you can see this.
That might be hard to see.
This is Bobby Lee's,
uh,
Skidmark.
It's really hard to see it right here.
Yeah,
I can't see it.
it's contrast is too fucked up.
Yeah.
So these things apparently it really depends who's making the east cigarette.
And so in that way,
like a company like those blue Easter eggs,
that might be like the way to go,
like Elise,
you can count on it because it's saying that kind of the same thing is pot.
Like when you buy a pot Brownie and you don't know what the fuck is in there,
like you're taking a total guess.
Right.
It's a big gamble.
The difference between the impact of a pot cook,
your co a pot Brownie can be you just mellow sitting in front of the TV or you
on a wild rollercoaster ride to the dark recesses of your soul.
Right.
You don't that feeling there's a big,
big,
big God damn difference.
And because the fact that it's illegal,
you know,
it's not regulated,
you don't know what you're getting.
That's probably the same thing with these east cigarettes
and sometimes like the,
the cheaper ones,
like the gas stations,
I'll have them now and you know,
you'd get the blue one,
that's the expensive kind,
but they all have like these like generic kind of versions of them and you get
some of those you suck on and you just get like a mouthful of juice sometimes
I'm like,
Eh,
that can't be good.
I'm taking like the juice that makes the smoke wringing out the filter at the
end of a cigarette.
Yeah.
It's not good.
There's certain things like,
like,
but you can count like one of the best things about,
uh,
like edibles is if you find a company that makes a certain animal and you know
what it is like they make a jolly rancher.
Okay.
This jolly ranchers,
very predictable one.
And you're good at light speed week does that,
yeah.
Their packages,
they have him.
How much they're very clever that way.
This east thing is interesting because they're starting to open up these
e-cigarette lounges and places that we've seen them.
Yeah,
yeah.
They have ecigarettes stores and e-cigarette lounges and they,
they serve different flavor.
Yeah.
It's weird.
People have like,
there's vaporizer store,
you know where it's going to do Joe.
It's going to make nonsmokers try it and then like it and then they're going to
get addicted to cigarettes and then here we go again.
Oh yeah.
Someone's going to think they look cool blowing smoke and they're going to fuck
them and they're just going to keep trying to look cool again.
Just keep,
keep trying to itch that scab gotta make you feel better.
It's like opium dance for people who aren't cool enough to smoke real
cigarettes.
Right.
Did you,
um,
you were,
you were in Alice and Addison last places.
Yeah.
Go back home.
I walk into a bar and everybody's just ripping cigarettes at the bar.
Yeah.
It's one of the last places that hangs in there.
Well,
when we performed there,
I was at the,
uh,
Addison Improv.
The last time was there.
I was like,
you guys have a goddamn smoking show.
I love it.
Like you have to specify and nonsmoking show.
Yeah.
If you're a headliner from out of town,
you have to let them know in advance.
No,
not even that.
Like they have an 8:00 PM nonsmoker.
Right?
Right.
There was like an 8:00 PM nonsmoking Sean.
It was a 10:00 PM regular show and the 10:00 PM regular shows just stuff.
Fucking haze of shitty decision making,
booze and cigarettes,
ski and Marlboro Lights.
I'm not a fan of cigarette smoke.
I don't like the way it smells.
I think it's disgusting.
I think it's bad for you.
But there's something about a bar that's filled with cigarette smoke that just
feels right.
Crowd of cigarette smoke,
cause they're always a little bit better.
For some reason they're fucking animals and not worried about shit as much.
They're not even caring about their own body.
You know,
Kinda two fucks.
Well it's a fact that girls who smoke or like much more likely to do something
freaky.
I'm so attracted to chicks.
You smoke cigarettes.
I don't know.
What are you telling me?
There's something sexy about that.
They're just making shitty decisions and the,
she's like,
you know how about one more on that cancer stick and you're like,
my Dick can't be nearly as dangerous.
Oh,
was she wrong after fuck cigarette?
Where you like just laying there or the during?
No,
they just seem to tell your friends who's also like knowing that they're not
going to stay good looking for very long because the cigarettes like more
valuable.
It's a shorter ride
to shorter wilder ride fatality.
That was all.
If a girl is like really smoking hard cigarettes by the time she hits 40 fucking
party's over and you're my grandma now.
The party's over.
Write that down.
It's true,
but a girl who's like a crossfit chick or something like that,
they could go deep in their forties and still like hot.
It's Pho yet?
Well,
there was just a picture on Facebook that was circulating where it has two
twins.
They're identical twins and one smoked for the last 15 years and then went
didn't it showed them side by side.
The smoker looked remarkably good.
The twins.
I was like,
this is actually not a very good argument because it's 14 years of enjoying
cigarettes and barely paid a price and having fun.
Yeah.
They're um,
like Halle Berry,
I think it's like 50 or something.
Like how old is she?
She's hot.
It's fuck man.
Does she smoke?
No,
of course not.
But I'm saying that's the difference.
Right?
If she did both of those lists,
be honest.
If I had to fuck one,
I don't know which one.
Should I click this?
Stop.
Shut this off.
Shaming this.
I'd rather watch beheading videos.
Shane,
you're shaming.
You're not supposed to do that one on the right.
Which one's the smoker?
Couldn't curl up.
Hey,
stop.
Don't show that anymore.
I'm sorry.
Don't be showing it for real.
Like that's not good Karma to just show people,
go look how ugly these people's faces are and just if that's on a line
somewhere,
that's one thing.
He's exactly what we're saying.
We're looking at it.
They're all beat up by cigarettes.
Were trying to figure out which one you would rather fuck.
I wouldn't have both been through hell.
Okay.
Let's be honest.
You wouldn't want your face appearing on a fucking a podcast.
Who would you rather fuck this guy or this guy with aids,
but the smoker,
the smoker would.
If she's still a smoker,
she would want to be on this podcast.
That's almost like maybe,
maybe it's just,
just want to borrow $5 come here and blow everybody for a dollar 50 a piece.
Be a disaster.
She's making shitty decisions.
They literally,
she left him,
put her face in that thing.
You know,
they probably gave her money for that.
She's like,
well,
no one's gonna see it.
Everyone's gonna see it.
Goddammit.
Brian just showed it to half a million.
[inaudible] sorry.
I'm sorry for that.
I wouldn't have done it,
ma'am.
I just want you to know.
I just think it's wrong.
Don't do it again.
You fuck.
It's the right one is the smoker.
Yes.
That's the one I would do.
The other one looks like she has a black,
nevermind just stumping me.
I don't want,
I mean,
don't be mean.
It's just a person,
man.
It's a person out there and making shit decisions,
but I support people's right to make shitty decisions.
There's something about the temporary nature of bar life and cigarette smoking,
but it's like it's kind of dying out and people are like clinging more to to,
to their existence and there's a part of me that enjoys a bar that's smokey.
Just like I enjoy being around drunk people sometimes I like,
I like drunk people that can handle it,
you know?
And I like a bar filled with people that are just out having a good fucking
time.
Yeah,
there's a lot more people that can handle it then can't handle it.
Right.
It's the people that can't handle it.
They're so outrageous.
They ruined the time for the people that can walk around throwing up and trash
cans in the middle of the street.
That's how it smell.
Like they handled it.
If they threw up in each other's underwear,
then it would be a problem.
Well,
there's a difference between going to a bar where,
but he's cool drinking,
having a good time and they go into like a a 50 cent shot night college bar.
Like that's when it fucking train radical pitcher nickel,
right?
Yeah.
Well it's like being around college drinkers.
It's just like being around white belts in Jiu Jitsu class.
They spazz out,
they don't know how to relax.
They're just,
they,
you know,
they don't know how to like go with their friends and just have a couple of
shots and clink glasses and go,
let's do a shot of Jack
for king hit knuckles together and you sit there and drink like nice people.
Right.
And you enjoy it and you have more laughs and you,
you talk more shit and you laugh at each other and you have a good time and it's
fun.
And it's a lot of hugs and high fives and shit.
A lot of hugs.
That's what it's like when we drink.
Well we drink,
it's,
there's no one gets any fights is no anger,
no breaks,
bottles and stabs people.
There's none of that going on.
You have to be a special type of fuck head to ruin a good drinking moment
unless you're drinking fireball.
Unless you were one of those dudes that just can't drink.
We know those dudes that are just nice guys but they just can't handle it.
They just can't do it.
It can't do it.
They try,
they can't pull it off,
can't fucking do it.
There's a lot of them.
They just got that broken gene in the man.
There's a lot more in California.
I noticed also I think there's a lot of psychologically damaged folks out here
that have come out here to reinvent themselves and I think you add alcohol to
that,
that particular mindset.
It's like the problem that I have with that is the same problem they have when
guys like doctor drew start talking shit about like the withdrawal syndromes
that are associated with weed.
I'm like how many people saying that?
It's like saying that peanuts will kill you because some people are allergic to
them.
Right?
Cause there's some people eat peanuts.
You're fucking dead.
It's not.
Most people though,
right?
If you're watching some report on peanuts killing people and you're eating
peanuts going without fuck,
are you talking about peanuts are delicious.
I had a peanut butter jelly sandwiches more.
I'm eating peanuts now.
I've got some honey roasted peanuts.
I got some salted peanuts.
I got some ropy.
Come on man.
Peanuts.
But peanuts do kill a certain percentage of the population that's a kin to the
same type of people that are getting withdrawal syndromes from weed.
That's not typical.
That's not,
no.
So when you pretend you're,
you're disingenuous if you're on TV pretending that it's a dangerous withdrawal
syndrome,
it's attached to the stronger weed today.
Um,
no it's not.
No,
it's just like people allergic to peanuts.
It's some rare freaks that smoke pot and next thing you know they're sucking
Dick for more pot.
Right.
Those are rare.
It doesn't happen very often.
I think the old way to meet and the,
with drinking now getting older,
the only,
the only problem I have is like the hangovers.
Rq.
So fucking brutal now man.
That's why you need one 80 from the onset.
When you were talking about the beginning,
I was like,
I'm like writing it down.
I'm like,
okay,
go ahead.
Well,
your body does not want you to do that.
I know,
but doesn't want you to drink like that.
You've got to drink a lot of water.
It's hard to do,
but if you do it while you're drinking,
it makes a big difference.
If like while you're drinking booze,
you force yourself to pound water.
You make a lot of trips to the bathroom.
Right?
But so what?
Just do it.
You'll feel way better.
It'll just go through your system better.
Your rehydrate better.
He's still gonna feel like shit though.
I just have it solid poop one of these days.
One day,
Brian,
if you plan and hope and wish and pray to the Po,
the poop ferry,
it'll all come out hard.
You're probably dying.
You're probably,
your body's probably slowly breaking down from the inside.
You're probably shitting away little pieces of your liver detox and right now I
haven't drank saying I like to not drink for a of days a week.
Yeah,
you don't
have to,
man.
It's just to your problem is you're in the social circles that are like,
you know,
everyone's drinking and that's,
that's how everybody gets laid.
You know,
which by the way,
the feminists think is rape.
We were talking about this on display with Kayla.
She's,
you know,
sober now and she was talking about hard.
It is,
thank God how hard it is to like actually get laid or how to like meet somebody.
Because when you're with a sober person,
like if you take a girl out that doesn't drink and you go,
oh,
that's the worst,
hardest thing to get to that first base.
Even because you're not,
you know,
you don't feel confident.
She is weird.
The weird thing that it actually is,
I'm going to stick your penis in her body.
Right.
It's weird.
You know,
it's,
it's only until people are drunk that it sounds like,
fuck yeah,
let's do this.
It'll grow.
Look at you.
You want to fuck.
Or what you're like,
whoa.
Rarely happens when girls are sober over and if they are sober and they say,
do you want to fuck or what?
Yeah,
exactly.
Probably crazy.
Probably going to burn your house down right after they,
fuck you.
Bitch is nuts.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
It's hard for a girl.
It's hard for anybody to trust anybody to be inside them.
It's very evasive.
It's weird.
But you only that dudes are like creeps.
There's a lot of rapists,
a lot of my stronger than women.
Women hear everyday about some guy in the news.
He forced himself on a girl and killed her and buried her body.
And there's crazy stories.
Like there was a kid recently in high school that killed one of the teachers,
cut it with a box cutter and dragged her into the woods behind the school.
What the fuck?
Yeah,
no one knows why or what.
Or there's the,
it's a mystery.
He's like 14 he was a well liked kid.
The whole thing is craziness.
And that's a boy.
You know?
Imagine men,
if I was a chicken,
be terrified to fuck a guy.
Yeah,
I mean they should be.
It's,
it's a,
it's a weird scenario and you know,
it's one of the only reasons why when you hear feminists talk about like how to
approach girls and how to respect the idea that these girls would be terrified
of you.
I agree with that whole heartedly.
100%.
It's one thing like,
I've heard it argued against that,
like the men's rights guys are like,
that's horse shit.
That's stupid.
You know,
not all guys are assholes.
He treated us like we're assholes.
It's sort of like manifest this whole,
you know,
attitude that certain men and women have with each other.
But that's easy for dudes to say because they're not getting raped,
you know,
and the men's rights guys,
one goofy thing that they fucking say they really need to shut the fuck up
about.
They'd go,
you know who gets raped more than anybody in this country?
Men,
men in prison
and in prison.
And it's a hard,
that's a hard,
no,
it's a fact.
Man in prison get rate more than anyone in this country.
We know what the problem with that fact is.
They get raped by men,
right?
It's black on black crime.
Okay.
The men are raping the men.
It's not women breaking into prisoner of raping fucking poor prisoners.
It's men raping men.
It supports women's idea that these men have fucking assholes.
It's exactly what they've been saying.
I mean it's ridiculous.
It's such a fucking asinine and disingenuous argument,
but would you agree?
Okay.
Feminist and then men's,
right.
Would you agree there's a balance in the middle,
like a woman's doesn't want some guy who's going to intimidate her and scare the
shit out of it,
but she doesn't want some pussy who doesn't know how to make a movie either.
As long as there's a fine line in the middle.
Yeah,
I,
well,
I think here's the problem with saying women want all right,
everybody wants something different.
Some women like Super Feminine,
really thin,
like heroin looking dudes.
Some women like guys with guts.
Some women like black guys,
someone,
women like Asian guys,
some women like timid guy.
Some women like aggressive guys.
Some women like to be held down so women like their hair polled.
Some women like to be choked.
Some women will fucking screaming,
stab you if you tried to choke them rightly so.
If you just try to grab them,
it's triangle him like your last girlfriend,
they'll fucking think you trying to rape them and they'll grab something,
stab you in the Dick.
That's normal too.
There's a weird broad spectrum of what people like and don't like.
So whenever you say,
we don't want a man that does this,
are you sure?
Because I've met girls that want that.
You know,
don't tell me that women don't like to be choked.
They won't face fucked because they do.
There's girls that like their face fucked.
Like I've,
I've seen it,
I've heard him say it.
I've heard the words,
which fucked my mouth.
Like Whoa,
Holy Shit.
You're the boss.
Yeah.
Puke on your Dick.
And it dries up and it's like a skeleton.
The next day,
the first time a girl said it to me,
I was young man.
I had never even heard it before.
I was like,
wait a minute.
What's my last girlfriend?
She would scream if I grabbed the back of her head and this girl was telling me
to fuck her face.
Like everyone's different.
Everyone's different.
That's what the problem with this whole women like this are men.
Men want a women who not every man wants a woman that does that.
There's a lot of Ben,
one weird shit.
There's a lot of men want a mommy.
A lot of men like women that punch them in the face.
There's this men that like there's a whole website's dedicated to getting kicked
in the balls by girls wearing stilettos.
There's a lot of weirdness in the world,
man.
You can't say men like this and women like that.
You can't,
you only thing you could do is be nice to each other.
That's the only thing he could do,
man or women.
So like the reason why feminism exists,
the only reason why it exists is because there's an imbalance.
If there wasn't an imbalance,
there wouldn't be.
This need to be extreme towards that side.
If it was like if men were like really kind to women and there was no dispute,
then there would be,
it would be,
it would be ridiculous to have feminism.
Nobody would believe in it.
The only reason why I can exist,
like whether you believe in a lot of the things that they generalize or not and
I don't,
I don't believe in the generalizations.
I believe there's a lot of good people out there and I think as soon as you
start lumping men in a general categories,
it's just like lumping women or anyone in the general categories were too broad
in a spectrum is always an exception.
Everything,
but there's too many different variables when it comes to humans interacting
with each other,
especially sexually.
But the only reason why feminism exists at all is because there's something
wrong.
If there was nothing wrong,
if there was no women that were getting shit on,
if there was no sexual harassment in the workplace,
if there was no discrimination when it comes to employment,
they're the don't know those things existed.
You couldn't make the argument.
It just,
it's that simple that nobody would buy it.
The women wouldn't buy,
nobody would join.
They'd be like,
what are you talking about?
Like every men,
men treat women like they're themselves living another life right now.
But that's not the case.
So when you have,
whether it's the men's rights guys or the feminist,
the reason why these groups exist is because something's wrong.
There's not a balance,
you know,
and there's always gonna be someone that's out there on the far end of the
seesaw trying to tip it one way or the other,
but that they exist because something's going on.
The men's rights guys exist because there's something going on because a lot of
guys do get fucked over in divorce.
Man,
I've seen it.
I've seen some brutal shit happened to men in marriages.
I've seen some men that were targeted by women who are just,
there were financial assassins and they went after men for their money and got
pregnant with these men for their money and stole money from these man.
I've seen it.
I know it happens.
I've seen it without this.
The baby part.
I've seen,
I've seen people get fucked over.
I've seen it happen many times.
That doesn't mean that the men's rights guys are right.
When they say stupid shit,
like men get raped more than women,
you know?
Yeah,
you fucking give raped by each other.
You'd dumped.
Fuck,
that's such a dumb thing to say.
It's just,
it's so,
it's like,
it's such a disingenuous argument.
Are you really worried about being raped dude,
cause I don't worry about it ever.
How about that took her to prison.
I don't worry about getting raped,
man.
That's never comes up.
No,
and I'm around UFC fighters all the time.
I'm around people who actually could rape me and it doesn't really come up.
I just went.
A guy says that if a guy was talking about divorce laws and the idea that you
know,
someone can actually target someone and someone can extract money from them by,
you know,
by basically a conspiracy,
you're conspiring to rip guys.
Awesome.
That's what a gold digger is.
It's a whole professional and there's songs about it.
I mean,
it's not like a kind of a myth,
like a unicorn or something like that.
It's not what Coupa cobre it's a real fucking thing.
It's a category in society.
Gold diggers,
and you know that's not good either.
But then there's the guys who fall for those traps.
What does that,
that's natural selection.
You stupid.
Fuck.
How do you,
how do you not look at her and look at you and not know she's after your money.
You're disgusting,
right?
What do you think?
It's your personality.
You know,
you're walking around with a fucking $10,000 watch on driving a Ferrari and you
wonder why women want you to pay for their rent.
Okay.
That's what you do.
Stupid within.
I'm on both sides.
Both sides of the fence.
That's how rocket.
But you know,
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to bridge gaps here.
I'm trying to bring people together.
I'm trying to let feminists and men's rights advocates and,
and everybody know that we're all just humans.
When I see,
like I was watching this thing about atheism plus,
I don't know if you know what a few of them isn't pluses.
She's the people that want to attach atheism with core values,
like against sexual harassment,
racial discrimination,
my,
and they would,
they had these really long verbose speeches,
but my problem with that,
when I was watching that,
I was like,
Duh.
Right,
That's what it essentially,
that's what it is.
Anyways.
It Gay Marriage de Racial Discrimination,
Duh.
You know,
w w sexual discrimination,
Duh.
All of its De,
yeah.
It shouldn't be there.
Right?
Everyone should just,
we should all know that.
It's like when you start railing on about it,
you make me want to sexually harass somebody because you're so fucking annoying
and it's so obvious what you're saying.
It's so stupid to keep harping on shit that I say we shouldn't stab babies.
Yes.
Those stabbing babies.
Profound.
Yeah.
Nobody,
well,
if you don't want gay people to get married,
you're a fucking asshole.
If you don't think that black people should have the same rate of pay as a white
person,
you're an asshole.
If you don't think black people should live in your neighborhood,
If you don't.
It's all nonsense.
It's,
it's so clear by this day and age that it's Duh.
So when I see something like atheism plus in these long drawn out speeches where
they're mentioning all these other things that we should already agree on,
like where are we starting from?
We starting from barbarism.
Are We fucking pirates?
Are we,
are we educating fucking horrible criminal people?
Our fee is like,
yeah.
It was like stop harping on this shit enough ready?
We should literally make two countries.
We should saw the fucking country in half and put up a giant fence.
And anybody who doesn't want gay marriage,
anybody who doesn't want black people,
anybody you know,
hates Asians,
get over there,
stop.
You need to figure it out on your own.
I tell many people have already figured it out.
Half the steps to I would say like a small island.
I looked like an island.
Just let it go and do that.
It might even be half the people,
but it's going to be,
but my point is if you're joining atheism plus Jesus fucking Christ,
aren't you already there?
I mean you really have to repeat that or I mean how much preaching to the choir
has to be done.
They have dog Chirp on that same shit that we all rational people already
agreeing.
Saw this pitch,
Roger Animoto or we'll take the left.
You take the right
go right and we can all live in each of the spots we want it to,
but let's,
let's recognize what we have over here.
We have a bunch of black haters,
bunch of Jew haters,
but you gay bashers all in one country.
We can give them Louisiana.
Not Louisiana is pretty full.
We should we give them North Dakota,
give them South Dakota.
Nobody even goes there.
I would say Rhode Island,
the move to South Dakota people to like Connecticut.
They'd be so happy.
This one spot to give him some upper Alaska areas.
Will they have camps?
That's what we should do.
Take Racist,
rally them up there quite a bit.
Camps,
I can live with polar bears.
You want to know how much you're going to love black people.
After nine months of living with polar bears,
I got an idea.
Let's take everybody and put them in a kid
that's never been done before.
This will glue the idea.
Well,
clearly we have too many people that suck.
It just,
it's so simple.
It's just don't be an asshole.
You don't need it.
It's,
it's so salty and it really,
in this day and age,
it's really all that's left.
You know,
if you,
I mean,
someone can say,
I am a blank.
Fill in the blank with the religion.
As soon as you,
religion involves killing people that don't believe in your religion,
you're an asshole.
It doesn't matter if you call yourself a Muslim or a Mormon or Christian.
You know any Christian that believes in killing people that don't believe in
Christ,
right?
You're missing it though.
You're missing a completely.
And what about that little voice in that site that just says this isn't,
this just doesn't feel right.
Some people don't have that voice.
Do they have voice and says,
eat the babies.
But that's a small minority of sociopaths.
I'm talking about even the most hardcore Christian it deep down inside of
someone's going to murder another,
you go add.
This just doesn't feel good if everything's going well.
See,
that's what the thing is though.
The thing is that only exists if everything's going well.
If everything's going well in people's lives and they're not living a really
savage existence where they're hardscrabble trying to feed their family and the
children.
Once that starts happening,
people get really savage.
Really?
Correct.
But what I'm saying is like a hardcore Christian,
deep down inside you know that it's not right.
You shouldn't be against gay people being happy you.
Why don't you listen to that voice,
but they don't know.
Because if,
if someone really believes in an ideology,
okay,
if you really believe in the teachings of the Bible,
there are passages in the Bible that you can interpret as saying that a man
should not lie with a man.
Sure.
And then if a man does that,
that man is against God.
And then if you get really crazy about defending God's will,
you might conceivably think that you're doing God's work by killing someone who
happens to be gay.
It's a ridiculous aspect of ideology.
It's a real problem.
There was a fucking crazy video that Sam Harris tweeted after he did my podcast.
We talked about Islam and we talked about,
um,
people that think that it's radical Islam,
but it's not radical Islam.
It's just some of the tenants of being a Muslim that they all believe in.
Find that video,
find that video.
It's a Sam Harris,
uh,
on.
It's actually on Sam harris.org.
It's on his website.
He Ha he wrote a whole blog post about it and then link the video and you watch
it.
And they're talking about stoning people to death for adultery and how many
people agree with it and they're all agreeing and raising their hands like,
no,
that just makes you an asshole.
Right?
That just makes you an asshole.
Try to find the video.
It's in there somewhere.
Yeah,
it says something.
That's it right there.
Islam or Islamophobia.
Now watch this.
And this is fascinating because this guy is really,
really confident when he's making this speech about what,
what,
uh,
Muslims believe and don't believe.
I mean,
this is actually islam.net.
This is not a website that's designed to like shame the Muslims.
They're very proud of what this guy is saying.
It's very radical.
It's really interesting.
Pull it,
pull it forward a little bit till you see the guy talking.
Okay.
How they always attack the Muslims or Islam in particular while
for four,
seven certain things.
For example,
about gays in the,
they're always attack us and the teachings towards this matter.
For example,
while in Christianity in Judaism it's the same punishment,
uh,
that exist.
You know,
I mean it's Harambe and uh,
so why they're always,
for example,
focusing on Islam and not a Judaism or Christianity.
While for example,
also on Jerusalem,
for those who've been to Jerusalem in the bosses,
in Jerusalem for example,
women's sits separate than men for example.
You know,
so why like five minutes ago or early,
we were asked about why Muslims,
uh,
has to be sitting separate,
you know,
men and women,
but they never ask these questions to Jews or Christians.
Why specifically Muslims or Islam?
Did you answer this question yesterday?
And you said that you need to ask the media.
Yeah,
he was an a tier,
but the other people were here.
There are other people will suffer because of you.
The answer's very simple.
Islam is the truth and in Christianity and Judaism and not the truth.
Oh,
what a great answer.
Can I get fucking change this topic?
Oh,
watch this.
This is where it gets interesting.
Yup,
but you are the shit.
You're the doctor.
I said,
can we have the camera?
Can we have this camera focusing on all the audience?
Sir,
can we have this camera focusing on all the audience?
Because
every now and then,
every time we have a conference,
every time we invite a speaker,
they always can come with the same accusations.
This speaker supports death penalty for homosexuals.
This speaker support death penalty for this crime,
this crime that he is homophobic,
they subjugate women,
etc. Etc.
Etc.
It's the same old stuff coming all the time and we always try to tell them.
I always try to tell them that,
look,
it's not that speaker that we are in whiting who has this extreme radical views.
As you say,
these are general views that every Muslim actually has.
Every Muslim believes in these things just because they're not telling you about
it.
Just because they're not out there in the media doesn't mean they don't believe
in them.
So I will ask you,
everyone in the room,
how many of you are normal?
Muslims do not extremist.
You're not radical.
This is normal Sunni Muslims.
Please raise your hands.
Everybody a lot.
So panela.
Okay,
take down your hands again.
How many of you agree that men and women should sit separate?
Please raise your hands.
They're all raising their hands,
by the way,
except for one bad ass.
What the fuck are in the front row that keeps his arms?
Everyone agreed now,
now it gets rather,
it's just this kind of losses.
So it's not just this radical shifts then a lot of work.
But next question.
How many of you agree that the punishments described in the Qur'an and the
sooner,
whether it is death,
whether it is stoning for adults or whatever it is,
if it is from a lot and his messenger,
that is the best punishment ever possible for humankind.
And that is what we should apply in the world.
Well,
who agrees with that?
Everyone raises their hand.
4,000 people.
La,
look,
what are you all radical extremists and they're all matte.
So all of you are saying that you are common Muslims.
You all go to the different massages.
No Way.
Or is it,
are you like a specific sect like the Islam Net sec to anything like that?
Are you like that?
Nah.
Is it?
Oh like the periods yet.
Please raise your hand if you like this extreme Islam,
that sector or anything like that.
No one raises their hand.
How many of you just go to this normal massage?
It's in Norway.
The normal student.
He must please raise your hands.
Everyone raises their hand.
Allahu Akbar.
So what's,
what's the politicians going to say now?
What does the media going to say now that we're all extremists were all
radicals.
We need to deport all of us from this country.
A law,
a law hawk.
Duck been duck.
Okay,
kill it.
Amazing.
Yeah,
but this is it.
Just because that group in particular is like going to it like a huge church and
then they're all just like,
yes,
we believe you.
Now are these just normal people?
Like if you go out on the street is in the Quran,
right?
Those are the punishments that are for homosexuality,
for adultery.
Those were the punishments,
right?
You're supposed to be killed.
And there were saying that every Muslim agrees with this.
Everyone at least in that group of 40,000 people agrees with that man.
Whether or not that carries over to larger groups or whether or not people have
a more moderate view.
That's a small group.
That small bro.
It's not the whole country,
but everyone in the group agreed.
It's a weird thing.
We couldn't get that many people and they're all raising their hands at throwing
rocks at people until they die.
But if you go to like one of our men and men and ministries,
you know,
like are people that,
the guys that always asks for money and you know,
like there's big groups of people at the church is that you have on late night
teenagers like,
but the administry if you see one of those and he did the same thing and then
I'll,
you know,
all those people might be like that.
You know what I mean?
It is,
it all likeminded people are drawn together
in one place.
It could be.
Yeah.
It could be,
but I think the difference being is that he's citing very specific passages in
the religion that deal with crimes and punishments and,
uh,
you know,
they,
they're,
they're agreeing on murder.
Oh yeah.
Basically because it's the truth.
Yeah.
Because it's the truth.
That's all he said.
It's just the truth.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
that becomes a problem.
Yeah.
That's,
that's like,
this is not just simply whether or not you think that other people should
believe what you believe,
but you believe if two guys fuck each other,
they should throw rocks at them.
Until they die.
If you look at this group,
if you really look at the people,
they're all young people,
they all look like call of duty players.
Actually I don't even see one old person over the age of 2030 I mean,
well it's Kinda hard to see quite honest.
You see some people in the front row,
but everything back behind that gets really blurry.
You don't really see how closely,
you know,
see a close up other faces.
But the front row.
Yeah,
definitely young people.
I think a lot of like,
you know,
radical religions,
they find people that are looking for guidance,
you know,
and they find people that are looking for some sort of a,
a clear pattern.
There's something about like that guy talking.
Okay.
He was so confident that everyone was going to raise their hand along with him.
Yeah.
And the things that he was saying,
there's a,
there's this like appeal to like being a part of that.
You know,
this is like this.
There's this,
you're drawn to the idea of being a part of this crazy group that is so down for
what they believe that they think that you should kill people with rocks have,
they don't fall some old old writing.
There's something appealing about that.
It becomes something like you,
you become like a part of like some bad ass group.
Have you joined up with that?
He become like a serious person who really believes in God.
Like,
Ooh,
it appeals to,
it appeals to a weird aspect of the human psyche.
What's that song was playing in the background?
I don't hear anything.
Oh Sir,
sir.
Something from someone's laptop or something leaking over a sound check to
islam.net.
Yeah.
What was that
freak out?
White people.
They probably don't even like that.
We want to freak them out.
It's like a televangelist.
This is what I was trying to think of earlier,
but that's what it seemed like.
It's,
um,
did it look like they were all on board with that though?
Because there was a lot of hesitation,
it seemed like on some of their faces.
That dude in the right hand corner with his arms crossed.
Yeah,
that motherfucker,
that guy never raised his hand.
He's just looking at the ground.
He looks pretty Russian,
but they,
a lot of them were kind of laughing a little bit like they weren't even like,
I don't know if we'd do 100% believe this.
Well,
I don't know about that.
I think you guys are looking into that when that dummy on to the right side,
because Islam is the true that you're the ball and Christianity and Judaism are
not the truth.
You shut up you Tommy,
you just trying to get friends.
You don't have any friends.
You want friends be on your side.
You're old,
you're old,
you're pretending.
That makes sense.
You don't have anybody to talk to you.
If you get that stupid beard and pair of glasses and a fucking blazer on,
like you're a college and you say that
in front of a group of people and don't know that it sounds retarded.
You don't have any friends.
Did you know that?
There's an oculus rift porn now I heard it's connected to like a fleshlight
device and then to sit there and you,
I heard,
what is the guy saying?
He's seeing an anime character that he's fucking crazy.
The more he fucks her,
the more he like.
That's so ridiculous.
And it's very south park like anime.
I don't want to see that guy's Dick.
I'm just know that you'll see some base.
Yeah,
hole.
It's a matter of time before they have a robot that fucks you.
Yeah.
I wonder if it'll be that first or it'll be like the new thing that Motorola
came up with.
If you've seen this,
it's a patent for a tattoo that they're going to tattoo a microphone on your
voicebox,
like some sort of electronic tattoo.
So they're going to literally implant,
they're going to start implanting microphones on people's necks and with that
you're going to be able to talk directly to the device without any distortion or
sound.
These aren't the droids.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's how it started.
I mean,
this is how it starts now.
It starts.
It's,
it's,
it's more like by your command for people that have problems talking,
you know,
like with throat cancer or something like that.
When I was a wall and it will have any bearing instead a voice box just to the
computer chip.
Yeah.
It's just a microphone.
It's only a microphone.
See this.
They're going to tattoo that shit.
Gangster style and your neck,
like
Ethan Hawke movie back when girls wanted to fuck him.
He probably did a few of these movies back when he was still kind of cute.
Now he's like a dad.
He's a dad and a horror movie a lot back.
Every horse.
He was a cute,
smart guy.
He's going to rescue you because you have that tattoo on your neck and starts
glowing.
Just means your life tokens or app or something.
Did I just make a plot for a new hit?
Someone called Michael Bay.
It's a great idea.
Are you going to go see Thor?
Oh yeah.
I would love to see Thor.
I love those movies.
I was at a huge marvel comics fan growing up,
so I see every one of those fucking things.
And iron man or what have you.
I enjoyed iron man three.
I thought it was kind of interesting.
It wasn't as good as iron man too,
but it's still a good ride.
Same thing with Wolverine.
I love the new wolverine.
It was the last one,
but it was all right.
You thought this,
you thought,
uh,
Orgill's is better than the new one?
Yeah.
Okay.
I thought it was,
I thought that one of the bones coming out of his novels [inaudible] come on,
there's a little,
but the Avengers,
this,
the hog scene alone for the Avengers was worth the price of division.
The Hog.
They have the whole down.
For the longest time they used to have to get a dude pretending to be the hall,
cause that was bullshit.
But now they can CGI the shit out of the hawk.
See only thing that works with CGI better than it works in real life because the
hulk is supposed to be this freakish thing that doesn't even really look
remotely like a person.
Right.
Not supposed to be a bodybuilder.
New One.
The new hoke is the shit,
dude.
Yeah.
I was worried about that at first cause I was,
I kind of like Edward Norton playing it and then I saw and he fucking knocked it
out of the park.
There was awesome.
Edward Norton gets suck it after you see the new one.
Yeah.
Over bitch.
What's this guy's name?
Mark Ruff.
Ruff.
Hello.
Yeah,
he's nailed it.
He's way better.
I believe that he's going to turn into the hulk.
That scene when he goes,
the trick is,
I'm always angry I best food scene in the movie.
I believe that that dude's just barely keeping it together and when he turns,
man,
it's fucking fantastic.
But I didn't buy scarlet Johannson surviving that bitch.
Please.
Oh,
you got some fucking flippy moves.
He got some gymnastics and you got the hawk chasing you running through walls
and you just managed to survive.
And even watching shield of police,
even watching agents of shield on NBC.
No,
it was it any good or whatever channels.
I'm watching TV shows,
Dude.
But that one guy is in the show,
the one that died in the crossers.
How the fuck he died in the Avengers.
Yeah,
I remember they make you figgy does they give you like a playing card or
something,
right?
That's right.
Yeah.
I don't know.
They can do whatever the fuck they want.
They bring people back with time machines and shit.
Comic books.
You believing it's Thor.
You believe in [inaudible] guy came from,
from another planet and our problem is there a guy that maybe died.
I'm not buying.
This is fucking show's over.
I buy that little skinny scientists guy can become a huge hulking 8,000 pound
green man,
but no,
I had to do it back flips.
Yeah.
I don't buy that.
The whole can fly through the air,
but he can't catch scarlet Johannsen that she does gymnastics to get away from
him.
He literally can leave like a bullet through the air and he can't catch her
bitch.
Continuity.
You fucks.
How about a little continuity?
How about right something that makes more sense and you don't have that scene.
Asshole.
I thought of the best shit was captain America and iron man duking it out in the
woods.
Upset with each other.
Well,
it was iron man and captain America.
They were talking shit to each other.
I remember it was Thor and Captain America.
Thor and Ironman went to war.
Right,
but captain America and iron man,
we're talking shit to each other cause it's captain America was like,
yeah,
who you are without that machine is right.
Bitch,
you're on steroids,
right?
Captain America.
I was like a little skinny guy.
They gave him like the Super Roy.
Yeah.
Come on sign.
This is stupid fucking argument we're having here.
That was a great scene.
Those are good movies,
man.
They're fun.
They're stupid,
they're fun and when they're over you feel like a boy again.
You'll feel like you just watched something retarded.
Nobody cried.
He didn't have to fucking explain yourself afterwards.
Well,
I felt like she was being unfair to him because his whole day you have to
interpret,
not interested.
She got blown up.
Yeah.
Women like to interpret films after they're over.
Guys like to try to fuck you,
which I do take it in a movie.
It's just we're just trying to give you something fun to do before we fuck you.
It's really nice to at least try to fuck you.
I mean,
maybe want to say it.
It's bad.
Good.
That looks good.
I heard
that was amazing.
It's so funny.
Everyone that says saw it said it was amazing.
It looks fucking does a lot of it in Columbus,
Ohio.
Let's film too,
by the way.
Fun Fact.
Really?
Yup.
It's good.
A lot of dumb people in Ohio
don't realize as Johnny maximum,
what are you retarded jackass yet?
Yeah,
if you don't know,
he looks,
that's the most amazing thing they can do now with,
with makeup.
You know,
like even back when Jamie Kennedy had that show that Jamie Kennedy experience,
those make,
it was a little sketchy,
right?
Like you had to be like kind of gullible to fall for it.
But now the goal,
I mean he looks like an old guy,
man.
It's perfect.
I would really like to see it in person.
You know what I mean?
We didn't,
have you ever seen that kind of makeup on somebody?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I saw when Kevin James was doing,
uh,
here comes the boom.
They made them up.
Like you got the shit kicked out of him,
do it.
I believed it.
Totally believe that he looked like a guy who just got beat up.
They gave him like welts.
They couldn't cuts and it was,
it was amazing.
Like they can make you look pretty fucked up and they can,
you know,
they can do some pretty amazing shit like with making you look old,
especially you can't make an old guy look young.
You got to do that with like special effects.
But you can make a young guy with cold pretty easy.
That would be cool if they can make little guys look young.
It never looks right.
It never looks right in the movies when they do that.
This thing that I've been doing for my back,
this uh,
Regino Keenan,
anybody,
if you have,
if anybody has a back injury and a like a bulging disc situation,
my bulging disc has completely gone away.
And uh,
I just found this out through Mris.
I had a six millimeter bulging disc in my neck that was numbing my fingers and
through spinal decompression,
which is this thing where like pulls on your neck and straightens.
It extends your discs and they they,
they draw back in and you do it slowly over a long period time.
Lot of stretching,
changing my diet,
a lot of rolfing and all that stuff and something called prolozone therapy,
which is prolotherapy,
which strengthens ligaments and tendons and it's mixed with ozone,
which helps you heal.
Just doing all that stuff.
My,
my disc is completely stopped swelling.
It's gone down to where it looks like a normal disc now,
which is crazy.
That means six millimeters went back in and I didn't do Jujitsu for more than
six months,
so I knew that I wasn't,
I just gave myself the time.
I was still able to work out in a lot of ways,
but I knew that if I got my neck yanked on again,
it would probably go right back.
Are you going to go back to Jujitsu?
Yeah,
definitely.
But now this regino keen stuff that I've been doing,
it's this thing that they developed in Germany and it's just blood spinning
procedure.
They take your blood and then they introduce it to heat and the heat makes your
blood,
uh,
grow like white blood cells,
I believe.
And then they spin it in a centrifuge and they draw this yellow liquid out of it
that turns out to be like the most potent anti inflammatory drug known to man.
And your own body makes it,
your blood makes it.
They figured this shit out in Germany and they do it in Santa Monica now,
but the guy in Germany has figured out a way to,
they're very close to being able to give you an injection that restarts your
body's production of Collagen,
which is what gives people wrinkles.
So when old dudes get wrinkles or old women get wrinkles,
this will let your body restart.
It's college production,
project production,
and your face,
your wrinkles,
your face will start to disappear.
There are two years away from curing wrinkles.
Incredible fuck cancer.
We got wrinkles.
While they're going to tell vein,
we are as a country,
we're going to have a lot of things down by,
they're going to die,
but you're going to look great.
They cure a lot of fucking cancer.
Now,
man,
a lot of Kansas when they pulled this out of you,
when they pull it,
they just inject it back in.
They,
they spin it in a centrifuge and there's,
if you go to a,
if you just look up the regino keen,
I think it's r,
they explained the process,
its course.
I think it has a different name in Germany.
It's called Ortho keen or something like that.
But basically it's a blood spinning procedure.
It's not like platelet rich plasma.
It's different and it's uh,
it's getting your blood to react to,
uh,
to heat and then they spin it and then they withdraw the stuff out of it.
And people with arthritis,
people that have like serious injuries.
Peyton manning started his football career.
Like he's,
he was like almost retiring.
He had two neck surgeries,
went to that dude in Germany,
Bam.
Playing football like a champ.
Now.
So many,
uh,
I know several MMA athletes that have gone over there.
They'll place in Santa Monica and the place in Germany.
You get their knees fixed.
People with like serious arthritis,
they,
they get shot with this stuff and within a week they have this an incredible
range of motion that they haven't had in years.
It's amazing stuff.
There's doctors are so fucking smart,
man.
There's just like every year they figuring out some new thing and every year
they're making people healthier,
fixing injuries.
I keep hearing that sound.
I think it's outside.
It's not,
it's not coming through the microphone.
It's coming through outside somewhere.
And I think it might be like a ups truck thing near me,
squeaky wheels.
But it's just,
it's so incredible when you see all the different shit.
Did you see that thing where a guy made a um,
um,
a three D in a three d printer made a,
uh,
an artificial hand for a son?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
For like 10 bucks.
Yeah.
They also figured out a way to make the first functional gun in a metal three d
printer.
They made a metal three d printer and they made a pistol and fired off 50 rounds
of this pistol.
That's scary though.
Fuck yeah,
that's fucking terrifying.
It's all crazy.
There's this,
the the hand,
this guy on,
he created this first you look at $10.
Hey that it's hard to see what that is.
It's good boy hand.
His hand is holding that object and he never had,
that's the metal things or his fingers.
Lo.
Yeah.
He's holding something.
A pipe
or something,
but we're really close.
I met a guy in New York when I was doing that.
See if you can click on that link.
It showed the video.
I met a guy in New York when we were doing um,
that a Scifi show that had a complete artificial hand.
I get that 10 bucks.
Amazing.
Hit with a fucking digital printer.
Costs me $50 to get headshots printed at Kinko's.
Okay.
I got a fucking hand.
Head shots are hilarious.
This one guy,
I'm in Australia,
got his leg and his arm bitten off by a shark and the God,
a new artificial arm and an artificial leg.
These robotic bionic carbon fiber arms and legs.
That's great.
And he walks around,
dude with no limp.
It's the weirdest shit ever.
We would find this man gets artificial limbs
after bitten off by a shark.
Okay.
Silver fineness.
Yeah.
Giant Shark.
Ooh.
Nope.
Killed Kill South American,
South African German tourists on life support after losing her arm in Hawaii.
While there's a lot of fucking people you killed by sharks,
dude reach
bionic leg helps shark attack.
Victim Walk.
Cause that it,
nope,
I mean it,
this is it.
Matt Lauer.
So what is being called the world's first bionic man,
and we're going to check him out in action in just a minute.
But first,
how the bionic man came to be,
what the fuck?
Not Right.
Not Lowers the bionic man.
That was creepy.
Oh,
a hundred percent biotic man.
Well that's Kinda interesting.
She has come.
It's a nearly bionic man assembled from prosthetics and artificial parts already
in real use in real people.
We might change what it means to be artificial halls,
artificial trachea,
authors by only cans,
artificial eyesight,
implantable kidney,
artificial blood,
bionic Exoskeleton,
restoring walking ability to people who are paralyzed.
28 different parts in all together for the first time.
Bear told Meyer,
a Swiss social psychologists hosting an upcoming special on the project.
That's crazy.
Whoa.
Yeah.
We're only a few hundred years away from not being able to tell whether or not a
person's a robot.
Yup.
In 200 years,
I think.
I'm not,
that's not even a conservative gamble.
200 years is,
it's probably not even a hundred really.
And when I say 200 years,
I mean,
that's like,
that's 100% right.
If we don't blow ourselves up 200 years from now,
if we make it to 200 already living among us guys.
Yes.
Just think about 200 years ago it was slavery was legal.
Right.
You know,
wrap your head around that.
Can you imagine what we're going to see?
Like when we're like super old,
like what we're going to tell our kids and grandkids 200 years ago,
no photographs.
Nope,
no cars slavery's legal fear riding around ha animals like an asshole Yogi have
a horse.
You take your stupid stinky horse everywhere and you have to tie it up and it
shits all over the place.
You know what the fuck that is?
A bunch of fucking gods up there.
Lightened candles.
Yeah.
No Way.
No,
200 years ago.
It's so long ago.
When you think of like if you had to go back in time and live like people live
200 years ago,
it would suck a fat one.
It wouldn't even be a little fun.
Everybody would die.
Every time the flu comes into town,
all your best friends are dead,
dead.
You don't live.
If you get an infection dead,
you just got to survive at that point.
200 years later,
we're talking about 200 years from now where there's robots that you literally
can't tell if it's a person or a robot.
Right?
For sure.
100% and no wrinkles.
I think they're already here.
Do you think the robot prostitutes would be the first market?
Oh yeah,
probably right.
Violence or sex.
How much?
How much blow back do you think there'll be with robot prostitutes if women,
you know,
what will women like draw a line in the sand?
That fucking robot is a cheating thing.
Oh Shit.
I'll find a way to justify that.
Yeah.
Like when will it come?
Like,
okay,
let's say like,
what if the robot looks like,
like this alien head doesn't look remotely like a person.
It looks fake as fuck.
The robot looks like this
by the way,
that one that you sent me the other art today or last night.
That's amaze.
Same Guy.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
That's a Zombie that he made for us.
Um,
I can't wait to see that in person.
Can you can't get normal people ordered these.
It's either my website,
I'll find out.
I'll find out what his,
what his deal is.
Uh,
his name is Francisco Hernandez and he's,
uh,
he's in La.
He's an La Guy,
but he made me this fucking dope ass Zombie is coming here and this week.
Yeah.
It's so cool to just be able to get a artists to create shit for us.
It's so cool.
So,
so many different things.
I've got to bring the gorilla in the,
the,
the Werewolf fucking the grill in the ass and still have that at home.
I just shows up,
shows up at the fucking ice house.
I'm like,
what is this?
I opened it up.
It's so fucking Werewolf fucking a gorilla in the ass.
The greatest cause of a,
an idea that I had a dream I had once werewolf and a gorilla having sex and I
was trying to like creep around the outside of the room so they didn't notice
and get out of there.
That didn't make me mad.
It made me the death squad cap,
but it has a huge hog.
Like a big Dick.
[inaudible] is awesome.
Dude's a freak.
So back to what you were saying,
so,
so something is ugly as like
they would still get mad if we had sex with it.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
If he gets to like,
if it looks like a fake thing,
women
probably,
it would be like treat it like a fleshlight.
Right.
But as it gets closer and closer to a real person,
like if it looks like Robby,
the robot from lost in space,
danger,
and you could stick your Dick in that.
No one's gonna say anything.
What would they let you print out a face of her though?
Like set of it looks just like your wife you have,
then you need that.
Why would you want to come home or faces covering seven inches.
A calm.
He never clean it.
You just keep shooting on her face and she's like,
what are you doing?
He tried to drown me.
Is this like some passive aggressive shit or you're drowned me and calm or
you're married to your Burnett and you come home and the robot's blonde.
Yeah.
And that's what she just freaks the fuck out.
You come home,
you're putting black face on your role.
Your wife like
know a teacher got fired in Toronto because he dressed up like Mr t for
Halloween and put blackface on.
Well you can't be Mr t without it.
How the fuck that is so dumb that you would,
a guy has a mister t outfit on and he's not allowed to darken his skin.
What kind of bullshit?
Pc World or we live at somebody in San Diego.
Same thing happened because he dressed up as a bobsled team member and team
member actually say,
oh no,
that's funny.
I like,
look,
I'm going to take the opposite on this.
Like all sip.
But they'd of that.
But if you're a teacher and you know how sensitive people are when you're
pulling your Mr t costume out of the closet,
you got to go,
you know what?
I probably shouldn't do this,
but your mayor smokes crack and shorts and no kidding.
It's gotta be that as you're applying back face as a teacher,
you should go,
and this is probably not going to sit well with people.
Assholes.
I love Toronto.
Toronto's the shit.
It's Toronto is the shit.
It's a,
it's an amazing,
amazing city.
It's really crazy because it's like a city,
but yet it's also like a bunch of really nice people.
It's almost like small towny,
you know?
It's,
it's very strange.
I think it's one of the rare cities in this,
in this country that has a very unique vibe of it's own.
Vancouver has a vibe of it's own as well.
Men.
Montreal has a vibe of it's own as well.
Very great vibe to Montreal is a great comedy town,
but Toronto,
I think it's my favorite city in Canada is just something special about that
place.
I would move there even though it's cold as fuck.
That's how much I love Toronto.
Like if shit got weird,
I don't know if I'd live in Vancouver,
I think I might live in Vancouver,
but Vancouver,
even though it doesn't get cold,
it gets like a lot of rainy and shit and Toronto is pretty dope and it's got a
great comedy community as well.
Yeah,
Toronto's got a suites.
It's a lot.
A lot of comics there.
Joey Diaz,
what the fuck are you on speaker phone?
I have some that you can't be calling me in the middle of the podcast,
Joey had dairy.
We have the exact same tone,
but yours is white and uh,
or black with a white case as the minds of white with a black case cases.
You want to buck here so you wouldn't want to know that.
I wanted to contrast.
Oh,
you're crazy.
I like the white case cause I can see it cause I would put the black case down.
Everything's black.
Black leather,
black.
Yeah.
I see.
I don't see it as much.
I like it.
I got this because they didn't have the black.
But then once I ordered the black and the mail,
I put the bark off.
So,
you know,
I like the white better.
But that case is the perfect case.
It's Kinda cool too.
When you close it like the window on the outside of it,
it shows the um,
makes a window.
Yeah,
it does a weird thing like camp you have like things like camera access can just
access your camera so much more you can do with these droid phones than with an
iPhone.
I mean,
it's a big goddamn difference.
I was about to jump over.
Yeah.
I hate my iPhone.
Well,
I don't hate the iPhone.
It's just too small.
Does the screen is just,
when you compare it even to the galaxy s four it's just too small.
Just need to catch up.
They need to catch up.
I don't think they're going to,
the thing that I,
one of the other reasons why I wanted to try a droid out because when I,
when I'm honest and I look at it,
I think apple makes the greatest computers on earth.
I don't see myself switching from the apple laptops.
I've tried windows.
I think they're too vulnerable.
I know,
I know Mac has a vulnerable as well.
I don't think it's as vulnerable and I just think it's higher quality.
I think they work better.
If I was on a budget,
fuck yeah,
I'd get a laptop from windows.
I'll get a like a Lenovo or something like that and when there's some good
brands,
but if you can afford it,
but apples are better.
But then I see all the different people that are working on phones and I go,
you know what?
I don't see it with phones anymore with phones.
I see too many companies that are working on android.
Too many.
There's too much competition there.
They're constantly innovating.
They're constantly cranking out new phones.
They have new features.
They have new camera,
mega pick,
like what does this and mega pixels in this fucking camera.
I don't know.
It's pretty good.
Some insane like 12 or some shit like that.
I don't even know what it is.
I do think I like the iPhone's camera a lot better though.
Yeah.
After using it a lot.
I you fuck with the settings though?
Well,
I have iPhone five s and the camera,
they,
they have a really nice lens in this wine and I think,
yeah,
it's way better than they.
I've been taking test shoots and stuff like that.
Still better.
I think that's too bad.
Why did they come out with a bigger fucking phone?
I would go back.
It's coming [inaudible] that I bet it's coming.
Dirty pitches get together.
Actually talk to somebody that knows like their friend works for Apple.
You got to get him fired.
I don't know that the person in my life,
I was just talking to him and he's like,
yeah.
Is he saying like how just sad it is right now?
Oh really?
Well,
it's just like everyone that even works there,
it's kind of not just excited and,
yeah,
yeah.
He's dead.
When a guy like Steve jobs is not alive anymore,
things are going to get weird.
That guy was like a primal force.
He was like a force of nature.
I mean the guy literally lived and breathed that company.
And when a guy like that,
he only took like a dollar in salary every year.
I mean it was like a maniac,
you know,
he lived for that fucking company and everybody says that he was a con and like
he would yell at employees and Shit.
But could you imagine if you were like incredibly obsessed motherfucker and your
employees were just regular people just going to work,
you're like,
yeah,
it ain't going to cut it.
Right.
You know,
you gotta be obsessed like me and like God an asshole and he is an asshole.
if people are having a job,
they shouldn't have to work 90 hours a week.
Okay.
But there's some companies like demand crazy shit like that.
And then eventually employees like wake up and go without fuck am I doing,
speaking of which cliffy bees coming on the podcast.
Yeah.
Soon speaking of free agents,
I,
there's a,
there's an APP that I don't want,
want to talk about.
Don't talk about it then bitch put his picture up on the screen.
The fuck is wrong with you.
What's wrong with it?
I want to tell you about,
everyone else is going to talk about it very soon.
So I don't know if we should even issue,
it's just a,
it's just one of these apps that,
you know,
as a guy you can't use,
but girls can and I've been trying to hack the system,
like make fake Facebook pages and all this stuff just so I can,
well,
it's all right.
Oh,
I know what you're talking about.
I know exactly what you're,
we'll talk,
we'll talk about this afterwards.
I don't even know what the fuck.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
Justin Foster,
what is the,
um,
the,
the process been like of moving from Dallas to La and was there any hiccups
along the way?
It was just frustrating at first.
Um,
because I mean like moving as a comic because you know,
when you're in a place for so long and you're used to regular stage time,
it used to doing,
you know,
and then you come here and it's like at for,
and you know,
first it's like two minutes at a coffee shop and then waiting around two hours
to do three minutes.
So that was kind of frustrating,
you know what I mean?
Cause I wanted to be at more right,
I guess.
And then after that,
then after awhile you can create,
this is a spot that you hit and everything.
Did you feel like,
was there any point in time where you felt like,
you know what,
I'm just fucking spinning my wheels.
I got to get back to Texas.
I got to get back to Texas and try to,
no,
there was a couple of times when I came really close moneywise I'm like,
fuck,
I'm running out of money.
And I don't want to be homeless,
but then something went out is something would come up and,
and I,
I felt that there was more of a challenge here because you do have to start
over.
I believe as a comic,
when you're anywhere else in the country,
when you come to La,
you have to start.
Unless you already established TV and Shit,
which I'm not.
You had to start over from the beginning and I kind of hated slash enjoyed that.
Yeah.
Even when I was on TV,
when I came here,
I was already on TV and I had an audition at the store.
I didn't get passed.
I was a non paid regularly for a few months and then I finally got a paid
regular status and they've got like late night spots.
But yeah,
you gotta pay your dues.
Maybe I didn't give a shit if he had a second.
No one gives a fuck.
How long have you been doing it in?
In what other town?
If you're not doing an la,
you're not really doing it.
Yeah.
It's a different thing.
It's also,
there's so many people out here,
they can't just trust you that you're good.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
It's just too,
just too many.
I mean,
you're going to go up at the comedy store or the laugh factory and there's going
to be 10 guys that have been on movies,
TV shows,
and a packed back to back to back to back,
and it all due in 15 minutes,
you know,
and you want your 15 minutes,
you gotta earn that Shit.
Right,
right.
Exactly.
And so it's easy to frustrated at first
and go,
Oh fuck this,
I'm going back home.
But then everybody I talked to was like,
you just gotta you just gotta fight through all that Shit.
How long you been here now?
Almost to two years.
Yeah.
You got to do one of our ice house shows.
I'd love to.
I love that place.
Yeah.
We'll probably do one.
Um,
not next Wednesday.
Not this Wednesday,
coming up in next Wednesday.
Done.
Cool.
Most likely if I,
uh,
if I got the time.
Um,
but in the new show that I'm doing at the ice house,
it's this new show called Thunderpussy that of course it's called Thunderpussy.
Hi Jeremiah Watkins.
Very funny comic.
He's,
he's been doing this show for a while and Hollywood and I got to do it once and
I'm like,
we need to do this big.
Uh,
what we do is we take seven comics and then we all go up on stage and people
from the audience yell out like things like,
like a microwave.
And then we kind of have to try to just make up comedy on the spot.
But it's a live podcast also.
So it's one of the first,
cause the comics have been asking me for awhile or people have been asking me
for a while to put a podcast up that should have stand up comedy.
And I was like,
no one wants to throw their,
there's material way like that.
So this is a perfect wave that comics and go on stage kind of showed their
improv skills,
you know,
and they don't care if it's online.
And I've been getting a lot of new material from it,
from doing it.
You know,
like I,
I've got two new bits off,
just people yelling shit out.
Got It.
Yeah,
that totally makes sense.
Especially like I used to do that,
uh,
after shows and do Q and A's.
But the problem with that is like,
you've already done like an hour and 10 minutes of actual comedy and then trying
to make some funny out of the Q and a.
Like sometimes it'll be a dropoff,
there'd be like crushing,
crushing,
you know,
everything was laugh,
laugh,
and then question,
answer.
It was like dragged out and weird and he didn't know how to end it.
And then you ended it and people on,
Oh,
is that good?
It was great for an hour and 10 minutes and then it just became,
you know,
it'd be fucking good at that Joe.
Yeah,
I would do it.
I'll definitely when,
when do you guys do it?
Would you like to do?
Uh,
usually it's Friday we have ice house chronicles,
you know,
but now we're doing every other Friday we're doing thunder places,
so,
but we'll do it whenever you want to do it.
Yeah.
I don't,
a Friday will ever work like a lot of times on Friday I'm working or both.
But we'll do it one one day eventually.
But um,
I'm going to do it so high I can't talk.
Yeah.
That's how I do it.
I get,
I get so drunk and stoned and then I just go crazy.
And it's fun because I've gotten so much.
It's a fun show.
Yeah.
That does sound like fun place to put yourself when you know you don't have an
act,
remember that'd be the perfect place to put yourself.
No stress and knowing you're only going to be up there for like five minutes in
10 minutes or whatever the fuck.
If you fuck up,
it's like,
well,
you guys should've picked something better to yell out.
Yeah.
And if you fuck up,
that's exactly right.
Well,
yeah,
this is on y'all.
Yeah.
Well you can,
you can have some fun times doing that with the right crowds too.
Especially if the crowd like develops like a feel for it.
And who's the kid who you do it with?
You?
Jeremiah Watkins.
Very funny guy.
Where's he from?
I got strong background.
I believe he's from California,
but he's got strong impression
background and his on my punk ethic last week.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
What's your pocket?
You got a podcast too?
Everyone's gone.
I figured
there wasn't enough uh,
comics in La doing podcasts.
There's no one.
You're amazing.
How'd you figure out how to do it?
It was an untapped market.
What's it called?
A foster.
The podcast foster.
The podcast kind of double entendre.
It's a,
it's basically just people come on and tell like a really quick,
awful story that most of them aren't comfortable with telling.
That's what you're a,
that's all it is.
Yeah.
Oh that's funny.
It's like 15 to 20 minutes.
Why do you always do that?
That's just,
it just entertains.
It's,
it's funny to see and hear shit cause I,
you think,
oh,
I've heard everything and then someone else will come on.
You make,
oh,
okay.
I haven't,
do you worry that you're gonna run out of like people coming up with crazy
stories though?
No.
Not In this task.
In this fucking town.
Not In this town.
Well,
plus if people find out that there's a venue for something like that.
Yeah.
That's all right.
Foster the podcast.
So they're real quick ones.
I think the longest one was like 30 minutes.
That's great.
Beautiful.
So yeah,
we'll,
we'll get you on a nice house.
Crockwell I remember you were really funny when we saw you in Texas.
Did you don't suck.
No idea.
No,
no.
Actually did you get better?
Actually gotten better.
Yeah.
And that's another thing being out here too.
It makes you,
it makes you better.
Yeah.
Well you gotta be inspired.
You're out here.
There's so many great comics we can get comfortable doing the same set all over
and over and that kind of moved to a new place.
Like,
all right,
I got to step it up a little bit so you can get comfortable at anytime.
Fuck yeah.
I'm constantly terrified of that.
It's important like whatever,
whenever I do something after it's done at fucking hate it cause I'm onto the
next thing like hypercritical about it.
Like Ah,
get it away from me and then I move on to the next one and that like motivates
me every time to make the next one better.
Whether I get there or not.
Arguable you know sometimes it's just like you got to figure out like what
topics have the most juice in him.
You know like you might have like a lot of material but there's topics that just
don't have the same people just not as interested in is like other ones.
Right.
You know and you find one that like really like hits a high interest level and
then you could juice it up with like big laughs too.
Like it's got a bunch of things going on.
People are excited that you're talking about it and then it's got a lot of funny
laugh.
And then there's other ones you're like trying to convince people of where do
you feel like it's forced?
Yeah,
sometimes and sometimes I think they're funny,
but other people don't see my sense of humor.
There's not as fucked up as me or whatever it is.
Then I drag them through this dark alley that they don't want to go to after.
I like send them down this beautiful flower field road for half an hour and then
I'm like,
hey,
take a left with me.
Yeah.
Let's talk about child molestation and TV.
Commercial
baby
has a beard.
He's driving a car with a grown woman.
What do you think's happening here?
Yeah,
there's a standup.
Comedy is just such a fucking open ended thing.
So one of my favorite parts about it.
So you never know where your next idea is going to come from.
You never know where your,
you know,
your next big bits going to come from,
what it's going to be about.
Right.
Do you write like as far as like standup,
do you right stand up in joke form or do you write blogs and pulleys standup out
ad Lib?
Shit.
I still do like pen and paper in the morning at the coffee shop.
Right.
You know writing,
I tried to go backwards of stuff cause when you first start I feel it's like
joke,
joke.
And then after a while you're like okay now I can actually go back and revisit
some things and put into joke form.
That was a little,
you know,
people weren't really,
didn't really want to hear in the beginning.
Yeah.
Some sometimes you have like a good premise but your s your skills are so
shitty.
You can't turn that good premise into a bit.
Like I'm doing something now.
Like if I woulda turned like about when I was younger,
I was in a mental hospital for depression.
If I would've tried to do that bit a year in it,
wouldn't you know what I mean?
And Nestle,
if you tried to do it in Texas and now you've writes all,
you're depressed,
you can't suck enough days.
How much did you sell going to the hospital?
And then now it's like well I'll just open with it cause I don't give a fuck
anymore.
You Open with that?
I did the other night,
I go,
here it is.
Here's the thing.
Wow.
Why were you in a mental hospital?
I was just severely depressed.
How old were you?
Uh,
I was like 13.
14.
Wow.
Yeah.
Damn.
That's real.
Yeah.
And so,
and but trying to talk about that,
the beginning of people would never go along with it and now you're like,
okay,
it's Kinda,
it's okay.
Now here's this thing.
Did you know then that you wanted to be a stand up?
Uh,
my mom tells this story and I don't remember this,
but when I was in second grade,
I was like an awful fucking student.
And the teacher was like,
if he doesn't get it together,
the only job he's gonna be able to do as like a standup comedian.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah.
So,
so I guess deep down,
yeah.
And maybe by default,
I don't know.
That's the worst motivation ever.
I know.
He doesn't get it together.
He's going to have the greatest job in the history of [inaudible] sleeping
whenever he wants to fuck her and drink every night.
You're going to have fun.
You're going to make people laugh in a way that very few people ever get to
experience in their life.
And you've got to get to do it twice a night on the weekends and never have a
nine to five people don't know,
like I did.
Um,
I just did Edmonton,
this river creek casino,
it's like 1800 people mobbed the laughs that come off at 1800 people when
they're howling killing it's electric.
You're fucking,
you're,
you get goosebumps on your goose bar invincible.
Well,
it's just,
you feel great and they feel great.
You feel like it's a good exchange.
Like you're happy that they're laughing,
you know,
it's like,
it's an honest,
happy,
happy exchange and you get to make it all happen.
Like they're sitting down there and they're watching and you're getting,
you get to make it all happen and watch the results instantly.
And as long as you keep working at it,
as long as you keep writing,
you know you're going to have some good sets and some bad sets and you're going
to have some good bits and some bad bits.
And if you put out 10 cds,
one of them,
you're not going to like that much or two of them where someone is going to be a
family like yeah,
I didn't like that one Justin.
It was just some about it.
You were all fucking weird and talking about flowers.
Right.
You know,
but,
but over it all,
if you have the right mindset and you continue to create and you continue to
write and perform,
it just keeps happening.
It just keeps happening.
If you give it what it needs,
you feed what it,
what it needs,
it keeps it keeps happening.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of guys that are like,
are perfect examples of that.
Like burr,
like Bellbird did,
uh,
the ice house show last week,
last Wednesday,
all new stuff fucks around on stage.
It's always fucking around,
always writing.
And he had a really good point about writing too.
He's like,
you should be able to come up with an hour a year because really all it is is 10
minutes a month.
Right?
Yeah,
it's true.
Yeah.
That's another guy just watching him like even like just working shit out.
Fucking brilliant.
10 minutes a month as 120 minutes a year.
So yeah,
I get,
yeah,
so if you wrote one good joke a week,
12 months,
10 minutes a month,
120 minutes a year.
I do about that.
And she
see you haven't seen me in a one stop,
you fucking line the,
you know,
you have some good ideas,
but you know,
the reality of bits is they're never done.
You've got to keep chopping away at them and editing them.
And so what you say is like 45 minutes.
It's really 15 it's 15 monster minutes.
That's what,
when I have an hour,
if I have an hour,
yeah,
I don't really have an hour.
What?
I have an hour,
five an hour.
I have 25 minutes of murder.
Right.
And I can,
I can turn that into an hour.
I can shop it into an assassinating 25 minutes and then sometimes extend.
Sure.
You haven't seen me in a lot.
I'm sure you got way better.
And probably the greatest comedian never.
No,
no,
I'm just saying that you don't know even know my material weeks ago.
Bitch.
The Ice House.
But you didn't see me doing my side bitch.
You saw audience members yelling at subjects to them.
I got the report back from the um,
comedy American comedy company.
Oh,
through report.
Oh cool.
I did awesome.
Yeah,
I heard you did good.
I did really good.
I really did.
Did Awesome.
I believe,
you know I did.
Yeah.
If you don't believe me,
that's just,
I said I believed you heard Sunday night was a little rough.
Oh my guess sets the guest.
That's where different.
I'm a front in front of Brian Collins crowd.
I just said,
all right.
Sunday.
That was a little rough.
Yeah.
Okay Joe.
So you know when there's somebody there to see you and then if there's somebody
other comic just comes on stage,
that's not their crowd.
You know,
it's going to be a little weird sometimes when he mixed certain crowds of people
don't know you.
Exactly.
And I think with you,
like we've heard talked about this before,
you get this Willy Wonka golden ticket where people already know you when you're
starting out.
There's pressure and that and then it's also,
it's also easier that way too.
Yeah.
But if you have a Sunday eight o'clock show and is not your audience and it's
somebody else's eye and said nausea from hangover and there's a lot of couples
there that probably don't want to hear about fucking dolphins and calm and,
and shit like that.
There's a lot of people don't want to heal.
You're what
those things.
That's the beautiful thing about performing.
For people that don't know you,
you know one of the good things about doing like pop in shows,
like think one thing that a lot of comics to do.
So I like to go up on a show where people are not coming to see them because
that way they'll get a more honest reaction.
Sure.
And sometimes it'll make you cultivate your bits for a new mind or for a new
ear.
You know,
someone who hasn't seen your stuff before.
But I also did five shows in the weekend and all of them were amazing sets.
So,
so amazing that that the owner of the club or at a three page letter
recommending me to other clubs.
Please.
It's so gross.
No,
but you're just saying,
I just said,
hey,
you did shitty in San Diego.
Say you did shit.
Like you were saying,
going to say is I heard Sunday night was rough for not just you.
It was,
it was rough for a lot of other people too.
Yeah,
right.
It was those shells thinking very rough.
Those are good for you.
Oh Dude,
they'll not gonna make you stronger than just eating Dick for 25 minutes.
Good.
Rough set is not bad.
But I heard you did very well,
but counts that you did very well.
But it's kind of gross to like Brag about the owner saying he did so awesome.
Oh,
I'm just saying that I think this is,
I believe you,
but you know,
and a lot of my set,
you're saying I only have a 15 minute set.
You haven't seen me do any of my sense.
Probably to have a,
I said if you say you have 50 new minutes,
you really have 45 minutes means in my eyes,
15 minutes.
It means like you chop out a half an hour always because what?
How much of it is your best stuff?
How much of it is stuff that you really happy with?
How much of it needs to be edited down?
That's just how I look at material period and that's what I said about myself.
If I have an hour,
I don't have an hour.
I have 25 minutes of murder.
That's what you have.
You have,
you chop things up and as you build up more time,
like that's what the difference between right after you release a special,
the new hour that you work on in the beginning,
man,
if it's an hour,
it might only be like 15 minutes that you really love.
You know?
It might be like a lot of other stuff that you're like ham and egg and song and
dancing and then as time goes on you start stacking and adding and then it
becomes something that you're really proud of.
That's a process you haven't gone through yet.
You haven't gone through the editing process,
you haven't gone through the process of creating an hour chopping it down,
eliminating certain bits and then stretching it out to a real legit beginning to
end professional hour.
It takes a lot of work.
I have about an hour 20 minutes now,
so I would say I have like what you're saying cause face,
well I mean as an example of here's what,
here's a bit,
I know,
I know I a bit dolphin bit that I can do at 13 minute thing,
an eight minute thing or a five minute thing.
When I do the five minute thing,
it's like me rushing it,
the whole thing and and hitting all the seven or eight minute one.
It's a good s edited version but the 13 minute one is more like free.
It's kind of like one of your old school bits,
you know where it's like very comfortable to be in this playground.
And when I go to the,
the joke to the joke,
to the tag,
it's very comfortable doing the 13 minute one.
But I've do all three like every week I do at least one to those is different
versions,
but it's always the 13 one it's really like,
all right,
that's the one that you need to do.
But so I have censored in edited different bits.
It depends on the show,
how much time I have.
Okay,
look Brian,
we all have different standards
and we all have different what we think are,
you know,
legit bits when with finger,
not legit,
but so when I think is a legit but new thing is legit,
but it's probably going to be very different.
I don't want to judge your material and I want to sit and break down your act
and tell you what you should or shouldn't do.
But people have a problem when you start saying how this is awesome and you did
so great and everybody wants the club owners writing letters for you and you
haven't seen me.
I'm doing awesome.
Now that I,
I saw you recently and it wasn't that long ago.
It was like you did Vancouver with me.
There was a couple of months ago.
That's not that long ago.
Thank Coover.
Yeah.
Did a theater in Vancouver.
It wasn't that long ago.
August.
Yeah,
I got four months ago.
Exactly.
It's a few months ago.
Give her a bit,
just not work for an array.
It just stops working like a budget kills all that.
It just stops.
Yeah,
for sure.
If you don't feel like it's,
um,
you could,
you could have a bit that it doesn't,
you don't feel like it works anymore.
Like it's not funny to you anymore,
right?
Like it might have worked in the beginning because you,
you saw the humor in it and then that as that adds like a certain amount of push
to a bit.
And if you all of a sudden decide that it's not for me anymore,
but it still works,
so I'll keep doing it.
They can sense that.
Well,
yeah.
Vancouver,
what are you talking about?
I didn't say anything bug you doing in Vancouver,
right.
Stop like making this about you,
man.
Come on.
All right.
I don't know why you're thinking I'm making it back.
You just try.
You just change the subject.
We were talking about creating bits and I don't know where you're like,
I did good in Vancouver.
You exactly made it about you.
Well,
you just made it as a reference.
Like I just saw you four months ago saying,
I just saw you had to go and you look.
Come on man.
How much better did you get in four months?
Did you get better in four months?
What?
I just said,
no,
I don't want to talk about this.
Brian interrupted a God damn conversation.
We were talking about standup comedy to make it about you.
That's what you just did.
We had gotten done talking about you.
We talked about you for a long time and then we started talking about creating
bits and then you started woo.
I was new,
but I did get in being so fucking what Jesus quite point was that I didn't do
good in Vancouver.
He did okay in Vancouver.
I saw.
No,
I saw you Brian,
and it was four months ago.
I saw it.
You're saying you're doing so much better now.
I mean,
how much better did you really get in four months?
I did good in Vancouver is what I'm saying.
Okay,
so I saw that.
Okay.
Right.
We're good.
Don't get too attached man.
Don't,
you know,
defining yourself like that and it's,
it's always ugly.
What do you mean defending myself or finding you're defining yourself as being
good.
It's not defending Brian I've said had a good set.
I'm not saying I'm amazing.
Like I'm not saying,
Hey,
I am the best comic in the road.
I'm not saying that you wanted to talk saying I had been goods,
I'm saying had good sets.
Do you not see the distasteful aspect of that,
that people would find that uncomfortable?
Like that had a good set?
No,
keep talking about it.
What do you mean talking about it?
I'm not,
you just fucking interrupted to say you did great.
Interrupted.
Um,
uh,
20 seconds after you saying something about me.
I said I saw you.
I didn't say it was bad.
I didn't say anything.
Well,
you just said you should think you've,
you've done better than Vancouver.
You think you've done that big of an improvement in four months.
That's saying that I wasn't doing good in Vancouver.
Not It's saying,
I saw you write the Vancouver.
That's what I'm saying.
Sorry.
It's not saying that you weren't good in Vancouver.
You're adding that yourself.
I said I saw you four months ago,
so if I saw you four months ago roughly.
I know like what you're doing.
Yeah.
What you're getting at it is I didn't do good in Vancouver.
It's not what I said.
I said,
I saw it.
You're saying you're doing so great.
I'm like,
I saw you four months ago.
That's what I saw.
Well you might want to relisten to it cause how you said it really bullshit
wasn't clear.
No,
because Brian,
I don't like when you want to talk about yourself and how great you do not
trying to take some uncomfortable.
I'm not trying to talk about myself.
They started this by saying that I heard I had to report back in San Diego so I
know how you good.
You didn't know.
It started by you telling me how great everything went.
I had a good set and that's when I said,
I heard that sunny knife was kinda rough.
I heard it was rough.
Right?
It wasn't as rough for you.
It was rough for other people.
Okay.
But he's a weird show looking at me and saying,
I heard it was rough applying to tell the truth.
When I have a rough show,
I tell the truth.
I don't just tell you everything is great.
I tell you about one shitty show one night for 30 minutes where we're having a
rough day.
It's getting booed.
Uh,
it was doing the dirty at 1230 show,
which is the fucking,
it's south point casino and it's a great room.
It's a great crowd.
But I just fucking that you weren't feeling,
it was like one o'clock in the morning and I fuck a bomb for eight.
It's like it felt like an hour and a half.
Those are hard shows.
Married those late night shows.
Late night shows are hard,
especially if nobody knows you from anything.
They don't want to see you.
Nothing wrong with bombing.
It's good for you.
Yeah.
You know,
it sucks at the time,
but God damn,
he gets something out of that.
Yeah.
We learn my biggest jumps I've ever made in my entire career.
Which for bombing.
Yeah,
for sure.
It just makes you reevaluate everything that makes you want to fucking jump on.
You ever quit on stage like I,
this is it.
It's my lens.
No,
never quit.
Like this is my last show,
but I walked off before my,
Oh really?
Yeah.
I'm always like mentally in my head I'm like,
fuck this up.
Dot.
Yeah.
It can.
It can fucking get rough,
dude.
It can get rough.
I mean that's one of the reasons why it's such an emotionally taxing job.
Yeah.
It's one of the reasons why people have so much of a hard time doing it.
It's one of the reasons why people quit too.
Let's start off.
They'll have a lot of good momentum and then they just bail on it.
They just can't take it anymore.
You think once it becomes like a business,
that's when it,
it,
it gets,
cause when you're in the beginning you're doing it for fun and you're kind of
going up in between your restaurant jobs.
So it was really like,
once you,
like,
it becomes a job.
I think it's when it's like,
fuck you should,
it should never be a job.
If it's a job,
you fucking up.
Well,
if you have to make money off of it,
yeah.
If it's a job,
you're fucking up.
you're,
I mean,
even if you have to make money off of it,
you can't just think of it as it,
it's gotta be an art form or it's never going to work.
Right.
If it's not something that you,
you're excited connected to creating,
you know,
and it's something that you're,
you're,
you're passionate about molding and putting together on stage.
I don't think it's ever going to work if you just like,
yeah,
I'm just going to punch in.
Right.
Those jokes.
There's nothing better than the calving.
A new joking,
like just being so excited.
Like,
I have to call us eat tonight and tell it like that's to me anyways.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I can get it can get really thrilling.
You know it's so wild thing to do with your time man.
Come up with some shit that you think is going to make people laugh.
Okay.
Cause it distasteful.
Filling this room.
Fill it
Joe carry way over there Brian.
Sorry.
It's all right buddy.
Happens.
Just got to recognize how other people would interact.
Like how other people would respond to people.
Whenever you say you're really good at anything or doing great in anything,
man,
there's a to
do that.
I'm setting a good it set,
it didn't seem as great at is a way to do that and there's a way to not do that.
It's not just that.
You said you had a good side,
you were talking about them manager writing you a letter and saying you did so
awesome.
Had a good set.
I know,
but you see that where that is,
it's like,
well if you're sticking that in people's faces,
you gotta be careful.
Okay.
I mean am I,
am I wrong?
After you just said,
I had a bad set.
Sorry.
I had a report card.
I heard it wasn't just you.
I heard several people on that show didn't do very well.
I heard it was tough.
I'm saying you gotta be honest about that too.
I mean on is,
I'm saying that,
you know what though?
When I got off stage,
people clapped.
It wasn't like I had a bad set where no one was like,
oh,
they're happy you were done.
Okay,
now you're just,
now you're just flipping the fish.
Look,
I had to say that Brian,
I can't just let you brag.
I have to.
I have to stop you for your own good.
I wasn't bragging.
Justin Foster,
do you know what Bragen sounds like?
I don't know.
Near the neck of the woods.
Do they have different,
different handles on what Bragen is?
I can't get weird for a second.
Can we wait for a second?
I felt like were like when mom and dad fight that just get real quiet.
Well,
you know what it is,
man.
It's like there's a lot riding on success and failure on stage and you know,
when you doing well,
which Brian's doing well,
you,
you want to let people know you're doing well.
That's what it is.
It's normal.
Just gotta be careful about it.
I said that stuff after you said what you said.
I didn't say that.
I don't know if that's true.
I don't know if that's true and I don't think you do either.
I don't really remember a hundred percent open to what it is.
I think you were saying how great it went and I said,
I heard Sunday night was rough and then I said,
no,
it wasn't rough.
I had a good weekend,
I had good sets.
Justin even said I,
he wrote Blah,
blah,
blah.
Right.
But,
but I said that I heard that Sunday night was rough and it was
rough.
And I would,
if you said that,
that to me,
I'd be like,
Ooh,
yeah,
I kind of eat dick on Sunday,
Sunday.
I just couldn't feel it.
They weren't failing me.
But that's not what you did.
You.
You went on to,
I didn't eat a dick Sunday.
I had,
I had a c plus set.
I had a middle of the line.
Normal set,
nothing to write home about.
Nothing that went,
oh,
that was horrible.
People didn't boo,
you know.
No one booed me once.
No.
Or they groaned.
Is that what they did?
Yes.
A woman grown when I was talking about fucking a dolphin.
I think that's something that a woman would that warrant.
So
those women,
I have the whole thing on tape.
If you went to the fucking tape crime.
Any,
no,
I don't need any proof band.
I mean my point wasn't whether or not you were doing good or not doing good.
My point was whether we discuss it on a podcast like that.
I know
I'm trying.
I can't think about anything else.
You could see the hilarity of my horrible set tomorrow at the Irvine Improv.
Oh,
I like how you worked at it and
you can moan at me and little Esther and Tony Hinchcliffe and Sarah Tiana.
Oh,
how dare you.
That's a good show.
It's a great show.
Tony Hinchcliffe was with me at Irvine.
Uh,
all last weekend.
Fucking kids getting funny.
He's really funny.
But man,
it's a great round too.
I don't want to say anything with that thrift store bit.
I won't say anything about what the bid is,
but that's fucking great man.
It's true too.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that Irvine Improv's fantastic.
Great.
Do you like it?
Is that your favorite?
One of the Improv's around this town?
It's a great club man.
Everyday.
Like the Ontario and the like all the other ones.
Cause we have like three really good improv's within like an hour and an hour
and a half away.
It's,
yeah,
there's a,
there's a ton of them.
There's the Hollywood one,
which is always awesome.
There's the Irvine,
there's the Ontario,
the Braya.
They're all fantastic.
They're all great.
Yeah.
Improv's are fucking amazing clubs,
man.
They're there.
There's so many of them.
There's all over the country.
You know,
a lot of people think that it's like kind of a a chain thing.
They're fucking up and ruling in comedy,
but they're also providing you a lot of God damn work.
Right.
There's work everywhere.
I was work all over the country.
The only thing that I don't like as if like they tell you that you're not
supposed to work the other club in town or one of those deals
that can be a problem.
Did it,
does it happen to you a lot,
you know?
Right.
And not to me it happens to some people.
Yeah.
Some,
some clubs,
you know,
they won't let you work the other club in the town and you know,
and that's all I know.
You,
you've had that happen before for sure.
Texas.
Uh,
no,
not in Texas,
but I,
but it was saying it's like somebody like you,
they put it probably it doesn't really,
they were like,
you know,
yeah.
If you can sell tickets,
they'll let you slide with stuff.
But if they felt like they can control you and some sort of a way,
they would definitely try to do it.
I think it's,
um,
it's,
you know,
it's a natural business practice and trying to get on the train to fucking lock
it down.
You know,
especially like if you're there on a week where no one's there,
that's when it becomes apparent.
Like if
you like the other side of town has a great comic and then this side of town,
you know the,
the,
the club suffering,
they have to decide what they're going to do because if you're going to work one
or the other,
if you work in one and they're doing well or you're working on the other club
and then the other clubs doing well,
like they have to be well,
hey,
well we're sucking it right now and we're sucking it because the guy that we
hire is now over there working for our enemy.
So,
right.
The fuck.
Yeah.
That's the problem when you got business,
you know,
business mixed with the idea of art.
Okay.
It's just fucking kiss.
Yes.
Problematic.
But you can't be a socialist comedian either.
Just give away your comedy for free.
Right.
Bring me food.
I'll tell you jokes.
Right.
Show was basically over about 15 minutes ago.
We're just droning on.
Hopefully we can recover from this.
Brian,
why?
I'm fine.
I'm not,
this is,
no,
he's still mad about rails.
I'm not,
no,
not at all.
But this thing went off the rails.
I'm the one who has to sort of like turn it into a podcast.
You know people love this shit anyways.
Some people love the ship.
Those people are annoying.
And those two,
those people are responding me on Twitter.
And guess what context I'm just going to block.
You.
Don't jump in.
Oh look,
I'm going to block this guy.
He's got a fucking swastika on his logo.
Yeah,
sorry.
Fuck face kind of block you.
It's a little logo.
Yeah,
it's got a fucking swastika.
It's putting it out there.
I don't know how it's like youtube,
there was a,
somebody sent me a video and only wants to hit the knee.
It was an inward music video time times two or something like that with thing
was called.
And it was just a guy dressed up like typical,
like,
like almost racist black slave style.
And the song was just inward,
inward,
inward.
And it was just,
it was a black guy doing it.
So I think that maybe that's the only reason why I could stay on Youtube.
But I was very shocked when people have like Twitter avatars and stuff like
that,
like really racist symbols.
And
how was that?
How did they get away with that shit?
You could get away with a lot.
If you're a black guy and you want to talk about black people,
right?
You know,
you can get a lot of your white guy and you want to talk about why people,
but Nan you,
uh,
I just don't,
yeah,
I can't wear black face and go to school.
Right.
Wrong.
It'd be Mr t I wonder if,
think I tried to it was it at one of her is at a party or if wonder if he went
to school as Mr [inaudible].
God,
I hope he did go to
because I think it was a day,
right?
It was a,
it was a school day.
The Halloween fell on,
could he get in trouble?
Say he was at a house party with adults and some I snapped a picture of him.
Could he get,
he could still get in trouble for that.
Right,
right.
I think probably how you think.
Yeah.
I don't think he would want stroll into class with black.
I pity the fool maybe did.
Maybe he's like,
look,
I'm Mr T.
Right,
and that's ballsy.
He said the the the lounge and they all drinking coffee together.
No,
it's not to do it.
What the fuck man.
All the other teachers like,
we're not gonna,
we're not going to get into this today.
Yeah.
They're like,
you can't do that.
Oh,
come opinion.
Full
painful.
Isn't that funny that that guy,
like he's like one of the only guys that you associate with like a giant chunk
of gold chains around your neck.
Like immediately you think of mister t like he made that as hook where I go,
if a guy had more than one chain,
you'd go,
we've got to Mr t starter kit.
Right,
right.
Some,
some guy,
if you were heckling him and you know,
the,
the chains were fake because the teacher couldn't afford that on a teacher
salary.
It seems like if this happened when the team was really popular,
that when it first came out in that time area,
that wouldn't be a big deal right now.
You can't do anything though.
Especially if you're a teacher.
Like my brother just got,
he had to delete his whole Facebook page.
He's like,
I'm not even gonna take any fucking chances.
Right.
So that guy should,
he should know better.
You can get in big trouble for almost anything.
Almost anything if you,
if you do anything that's non PC outside of work.
Some girl got fired because they took a picture on her Facebook of her boyfriend
holding her tit and they let her go.
Yeah,
they fired her.
She was a teacher.
I was holding her tit.
I mean it wasn't even like holding nipple.
It wasn't like Penn just grabbing a tet squeezing like some bottom meet
the fuck man.
There's a weirdness going on in the world where people are just super fucking
sensitive,
super duper sentence.
They want people want to get other people in trouble too.
That's the thing.
Everybody's wants to be the first to like catch somebody doing something,
an act.
It'd be the first to,
you know,
get somebody fired.
Right.
Yeah.
That's a thing too.
They want to catch people and things so there's a lot of miserable fucks out
there working stuck in jobs they don't like and it just,
Ooh,
they got this built up and if they can point it at you and get you in trouble
for something because there's a whole bunch of rules that everybody has got to
follow in.
A lot of them are ridiculous rules.
They feel better.
You the PC police,
it's just so out of control.
But you know,
in some ways it's got to be there because if you're working,
like say if you're a woman and you're working in some fucking office with some
guy who tells Dick Jokes all the time,
it talks about fucking like you shouldn't have to deal with that.
You shouldn't have to go in there but,
but because there's Douche bags that ruined that shit,
then there's always going to be like,
you can't have a funny joke either.
Like sometimes someone's not a Douche bag,
but they have the funny thing to say and it's just the right time.
Right,
and it's inappropriate,
but you know they don't mean it,
but they can get away with it.
That's like the problem with humor.
Like in a workplace you can't take that chance.
I think it has to do a lot of who the person is to the charming you are,
the more you can get away with.
The creepy guy at the office can say the same thing and people are like,
ah,
no,
it's gets stifled.
You know it.
It's gets stifled because it has to get stifled because if you just go free
range,
wild,
wild west,
die with your jokes,
like you're doing a podcast or something.
Right.
You know,
some people are going to get really fucking offended at you,
but who,
but my question is like what PR is and here's what it was,
was probably a parent of a teacher that she'd probably be reprimanded.
It was like,
oh,
this be telling me how to raise my kids.
Scrolling through a Facebook page and go on.
How dare lady with a boyfriend with having fun.
Tell me how to raise kid.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
That could definitely be it.
Some woman doesn't want some fucking slut reasoner religion.
That could be it.
Or some checkers just upset that she's hot enough for someone to grab her tits
and she hasn't gotten laid since her fucking husband cheated on it.
Dirty Bitch.
Yeah.
Grabbing tin on Facebook.
I'll show her.
That could be that too.
All right.
Justin Foster people can find you on Twitter.
It's Justin comic on Twitter.
Yup.
And do you have a website too?
Yeah.
Justin comic.
Justin Connolly.
Yup.
You were the only Justin comic to scoop that shit on.
I was the first.
It had to be somebody else who thought that up.
So get you to buy it from me.
Do you find that there may be an issue with people remembering the name foster?
Uh,
Nah.
I don't think so.
I hope not.
All right.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for being here man.
Thanks for being here for a nice little hissy fit.
Yeah,
that was fun.
We made up buddy.
Yeah,
that was good.
I was just trying to help everybody here folks.
I just have a a very strong opinion on certain things.
I don't mean to hurt anybody's feelings.
We don't mean to just,
we smoke a little weed and sometimes we just talk.
Sometimes shit goes awry.
Just like comedy set by Justin Foster.
All right,
fuckers.
We'll be back.
We'll be back soon.
Lots of podcasts this week and a casket.
Berrien,
did I say name right and I'm also a Graham Hancock and this episode is brought
to you by 10 if you go to rogan.ting.com you will save 25 bucks off of any of
their new suite.
Sleek,
delicious android devices.
You're also brought to you by Hulu plus.
If you go to Hulu plus.com forward slash,
Rogen you can get a free trial and try it for two weeks.
Try Hulu plus for two weeks,
Hulu plus.com forward slash Rogen and thanks also to [inaudible] Dot com go to
o.N n I.
T you use the code name,
Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
folks.
We'll see soon.
Okay.